Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft.
Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße zur Ausgabe 83 hier bei Forschergeist.
Und ja, heute haben wir dann doch mal ein richtig gut in die Zeit passendes Thema, auch wenn das schon lange lange lange im Regal lag,
um endlich mal zur Anwendung hier zu kommen, aber es ist halt derzeit gar nicht so einfach, die Gespräche so zu führen, wie wir es gewohnt sind.
Aber heute ist es soweit und wir tauchen heute ein in den Bereich der Biotechnologie oder genauer des Bioengineerings.
Was da alles dahintersteckt, das erläutert unser Gesprächspartner, nämlich Joachim Fensterle, schönen guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
Ja, Herr Fensterle, Sie sind Bioingenieur, könnte man fast sagen.
Ich weiß, das trifft es nur ansatzweise, aber das ist Ihr Feld, Biotechnologie.
Genau, ja.
Bioengineering, Biotechnologie.
Bioengineering steht auf dem Klingelschild, aber gleichzeitig Biotechnologie auch und ich würde mich selber eher als Biotechnologe denn als Bioingenieur bezeichnen.
Ja okay, aber nicht unbedingt als Biologe?
Das klingt schon fast wie ein Schimpfwort.
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich glaube, der Biologe der kann viele Sachen mehr, zum Beispiel der kann, wenn wir jetzt in den Wald gingen und Sie mich fragen,
was ist das für ein Baum, dann kann es Ihnen der Biologe sagen, ich nicht.
Daher würde ich mich garantiert nicht als Biologe bezeichnen dürfen.
Hier geht es darum, Krankheiten zu erkennen, zu bekämpfen, zu verstehen.
Die ganzen molekularen Grundlagen zu verstehen und Wege zu finden, dort Ansätze für die Medizin zu suchen.
Wenn ich das mal so locker zusammenfassen darf.
Bei mir ging es immer lange drum.
Ich denke, Biotechnologie ist natürlich eigentlich alles, sobald Sie irgendwas anwenden, was dem Menschen hilft.
Ob es Biogas ist oder der neue Impfstoff gegen einen Infektionserreger, das ist alles Biotechnologie, also das ist ein sehr weites Feld.
Und ich komme eher aus dem medizinischen Bereich.
Okay, aber wie hat das denn angefangen?
Was hat denn überhaupt das wissenschaftliche Interesse geweckt bei Ihnen?
Naja, die Frage ist, wann hat es angefangen, also wie weit geht man zurück?
Ich wollte schon immer irgendwas …
Soweit wie es geht.
Sie sehen es an meiner Haarfarbe, das sehen die Zuhörer jetzt natürlich nicht, aber Sie können es mir glauben, die ist relativ ergraut,
das heißt, es geht leider ein Weilchen zurück.
Aber für mich war schon immer klar, immer immer, dass irgendwas mit Naturwissenschaften auf dem Plan steht.
Warum war das klar?
Weil mich das immer schon begeistert hat.
Also dieses wie die Natur funktioniert, diese Faszination für das Komplizierte, das so ein bisschen zu verstehen und dann natürlich festzustellen…
Hattest du das schon im Kindergarten oder?
Ach ich würde mal sagen, meinen Chemiebaukasten habe ich in der siebten Klasse bekommen, aber gewünscht habe ich mir den eigentlich schon mit der vierten Klasse,
aber da haben meine Eltern und meine großen Geschwister beschlossen, das ist noch ein bisschen zu früh.
Also Kindergarten wahrscheinlich noch nicht ganz.
Was hätte aus dem Jungen werden können?
Ja genau, was hätte aus dem Jungen werde können?
So ungefähr.
Gut, das heißt, es ging dann relativ schnell in Richtung Studium?
Genau, also mir war klar, dass ich dann mit, sagen wir mal, zehnte Klasse oder so, dass es auf Biotechnologie rausläuft.
Da habe ich auch eine Biotechnologie AG gemacht, da haben wir sogar zum ersten Mal kloniert in dieser AG.
Das ist schon gefühlte hundert Jahre her.
Hat nicht funktioniert, aber es war total klasse, weil das waren nur zwei Leute, ein Mitschüler und ich und der Lehrer.
Und der natürlich selber mit uns dann das so mit gelernt hat, weil in der Schule hat man das damals ja sicher noch nicht groß gemacht
und wir hatten versucht, eine Karotte wieder zu züchten aus Kallusgewebe.
Wie gesagt, das hat nicht funktioniert, das ist dann irgendwann weggeschimmelt, aber trotzdem das waren die Anfänge.
Und dann war mir klar, das ist wirklich das, was ich mal machen will.
Weniger die Karotten, aber der Bereich.
Welches Studium ist es denn dann geworden?
Es ist direkt Biotechnologie geworden.
Also ich habe dann in Braunschweig angefangen mit Biotechnologie.
Damals war das noch anders wie heute, heute hat man natürlich zehn Millionen Biotechnologiestudiengänge, damals gab es das in Stuttgart, in Braunschweig und in Berlin.
Der Name war immer ein bisschen anders, aber de facto Biotechnologie.
Und das in Braunschweig hat mir eigentlich so vom Papier her am meisten gefallen, da bin ich dann da hin und habe es nie bereut.
Und nach zwei Jahren bin ich dann nach Straßburg gewechselt, weiterhin Biotechnologie, dort an der Grand École für Biotechnologie weiter studiert.
Aber was heißt denn das jetzt eigentlich, Biotechnologie studieren?
Also man kriegt schon die biologischen Grundlagen, aber man spezialisiert sich nur mehr oder kommt da noch irgendwie ein ganz anderes Feld noch hinzu?
Also ist es sozusagen auch wirklich mehr technologisch oder ist es mehr Bio, also wie ist da die Abwägung?
Jetzt mein Problem ist natürlich, dass ich jetzt auch Professor bin und natürlich nicht die zukünftigen Studierenden abschrecken möchte,
wenn ich jetzt hier was falsches sage.
Also das Problem an der Biotechnologie ist gleichzeitig das Tolle, dass eigentlich alles drunterfällt.
Und das bedeutet natürlich im Studium, dass es wahnsinnig breit ist.
Also es ist genau das Gegenteil von dem, was Sie jetzt angesprochen haben.
Man kann sich dann natürlich spezialisieren, aber am Anfang heißt Biotechnologie viel Mathe, Ingenieurswissenschaften, Molekularbiologie, Biochemie, Chemie,
Physik, Verfahrenstechnik und so weiter, das ist dann alles drin.
Und da muss man sich dann halt durch alle so ein bisschen durchbeißen, aber man hat dann ein sehr breites Fundament, auf dem man dann aufbauen kann und sich spezialisieren kann.
Und das macht wirklich Spaß.
Also wenn man dieses Zwischendurchbeißen überwunden hat, fast jeder Studierende in dem Bereich früher oder später hat, weil sie unweigerlich natürlich Gebiete haben,
die Ihnen nicht so liegen.
Wenn Sie so viele verschiedene Sachen machen müssen, gibt es immer das eine oder das andere, wo Sie sagen, das muss jetzt nicht so sein.
Aber wenn man sich dann durchgebissen hat, macht es richtig Spaß, weil man einfach so einen umfassenden Blick entwickeln kann.
Und das ist eigentlich Biotechnologie.
Also Biotechnologie ist halt, wenn Sie nach einer Definition zum Beispiel suchen, stellt man schnell fest, dass es gar keine so befriedigende Definition der Biotechnologie gibt.
Im Wesentlichen ist es alles, die Natur zu verstehen und anzuwenden, dass es dem Menschen weiterhilft.
Das ist so die allgemeinste Definition der Biotechnologie, die eigentlich auch unbefriedigend ist, aber die fasst das eigentlich ganz gut,
und da fällt natürlich dann wahnsinnig viel drunter.
Ja und es ist vor allem auch die unmittelbare Verbindung zwischen der Technologie an sich des Menschen, alles was wir so über die Jahrhunderte für uns geschaffen haben,
aber die eben konkret versucht, unmittelbar an die Natur anzudocken, und zwar jetzt nicht nur als Umwelttechnologie, sondern eben potenziell eben auch an uns selbst andockt.
Genau, also das bedeutet einfach, im Wesentlichen ist Biotechnologie natürlich Leben zu verstehen und daraus Nutzen zu ziehen.
Das kann man auch so formulieren.
Und das war vielleicht auch das am Anfang, mein Physiklehrer war sich sicher, dass ich mal Physik studiere, aber da war ich mir sicher, das mach ich nicht,
weil Physik ist natürlich auch ganz toll, also nicht dass jetzt irgendein Physiker, der dem Podcast zuhört, sofort abschaltet, aber das ist natürlich anders.
Also das Leben, ich finde das Tolle am Leben ist, es ist einfach viel überraschender.
Also es gibt so oft diese Geschehnisse, dass man ein Experiment macht oder so, wo man vollkommen unerwartete Resultate rauskriegt.
Und diesen Effekt hat man in der Physik wahrscheinlich ein bisschen seltener.
Wenn man ihn hat, dann weiß man, dass man kurz vor dem Nobelpreis steht.
Genau. Bei der Biologie heißt es eher, das ist leider nicht der Nobelpreis, sondern man muss wieder komplett neu ansetzen und neu denken und das nochmal neu machen,
aber das macht einfach Spaß dieses Überraschende, das Neue.
Aber dann kam es dann doch zu etwas Spezialisierung mit dem Wechsel nach Berlin zum Max-Planck-Institut für Infektionsbiologie.
Genau, also man kann natürlich nicht sein Leben lang alles machen.
Also diese Universalgelernten a la Goethe oder so, die gibt es heute nicht mehr und das ist ja auch klar, man muss sich spezialisieren.
Also man hat das Fundament und man kann dann schon, heutzutage hat man Bachelor und Master, das gab es damals natürlich noch nicht,
aber schon jetzt ist es so, dass man im Master schon eine gewisse Spezialisierung macht, was auch normal ist.
Bei mir war das eigentlich schon bei der Bachelorarbeit, also Bachelorarbeit sage ich jetzt schon, bei der Diplomarbeit so, ich war dann in Siena bei Chiron Biocine
und das war damals, die wurden von Novartis übernommen, ich weiß gar nicht, ob die jetzt immer noch Impfstoffe machen,
dort eine der führenden Impfstoffforschungen dort in Siena und die haben die ganzen Kinderimpfstoffe, wie Pertussis und so weiter, die wurden dort entwickelt,
also die sind dort gemacht, entwickelt worden, die jetzt hier die ganzen Kinder mit ihrer Fünffachimpfung kriegen, nicht alle, aber relativ große Zahl.
Und da war für mich schon diese Richtung Immunologie und Impfstoffforschung war da klar.
Und dann habe ich halt natürlich geschaut, was passt von der Promotion…
Warum?
Warum war das so, also ich meine, warum wählt man sich das aus, wenn da jetzt sozusagen so ein breites Feld vor Ihnen lag und alles wäre möglich gewesen,
warum stürzt man sich dann auf das Thema?
Eigentlich muss man ja schon fast ein schlechtes Gewissen haben, wenn man irgendwas raussucht, hat man immer…
Weil natürlich ist es auch so, das andere ist auch spannend, also ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass das einzig tolle Gebiet ist,
aber ich glaube, sobald man mal anfängt was zu vertiefen, dann entwickelt man sich dort dann auch weiter
und wenn einem das Spaß macht, dann macht es natürlich auch Sinn.
Und natürlich wirklich Fortschritt entsteht natürlich dann auch nur, wenn man wirklich Experte wird in einem bestimmten Gebiet.
Ja, das muss man dann sein, also man kann nicht durch zwei Publikationen lesen, plötzlich dann der große Immunologe werden,
sondern das geht nur, wenn man sich in dem Gebiet dann auch wirklich vertieft.
Und das macht dann auch, je tiefer man reingeht in ein Gebiet, desto mehr macht es Spaß, weil dann diese Zusammenhänge innerhalb dieses Gebietes einem auch klar werden.
Und beispielsweise für mich so ein Aha-Erlebnis war, das ist gar nicht publiziert, aber das war vor, oh jetzt will ich nicht lügen, 96 glaube ich war das die Diplomarbeit.
Es ging um Hepatitis C, gegen den gibt es immer noch keinen Impfstoff, also wir können froh sein, dass Corona nicht Hepatitis C ist.
Da ging es drum zu erkennen, warum bestimmte Arten von Impfstoffen haben neutralisierende Antikörper gemacht, andere nicht.
Und ich war dann irgendwann bei meinem Chef drin in Siena und habe gesagt, die Daten, wenn ich die alle zusammenpacke,
wenn ich das so sehe dann liegt das wahrscheinlich daran, dass dieser Virus nicht wie die meisten anderen Viren an der Zellmembran rausgeht,
sondern dass er in die Zelle reinbudded.
Also da gibt es verschiedene Strukturen in der Zelle, vielleicht jeder in der Schule musste das mal lernen, endoplasmatisches Retikulum und Golgi-Apparat,
das hat man in Biologie Klasse 11 und 12, das lernt man dann auswendig, dann hat man die Zelle, dann hat man es wieder vergessen.
Also für die Leute, die das so im Hinterkopf haben, im Prinzip sind das Membranen in der Zelle drin, wo jetzt Proteine, wenn ich jetzt Antikörper zum Beispiel mache in einer B-Zelle,
dann wird der Antikörper in dieses
dann wird der Antikörper in dieses Membransystem reinsynthetisiert und was da reingeht, kann dann auch nach außen sekretiert werden. Membransystem rein synthetisiert und was da reingeht, kann dann auch nach außen sekretiert werden.
Das ist so der Transportweg dann.
Und ich habe meinem damaligen Chef postuliert,die Ergebnisse machen dann Sinn, wenn dieser Virus das genauso macht wie ein Antikörper,
dass der in dieses System reinbudded sozusagen und durch dieses System ausgeschleust wird.
Und tatsächlich hat sich später das rausgeschleust, dass es tatsächlich so ist.
Und das ist einfach dann toll, wenn man so ein Erlebnis hat.
Das war damals noch nicht publiziert, also das nützt auch jetzt in dem Sinne nichts,
aber wenn man dann diese Stufe erreicht hat, wo man auch mal was neues zusammenfassen kann, so eine Synthese machen kann, dann macht das auch Spaß
und dann will man dann natürlich da auch weitermachen.
Das ist so vielleicht die Erklärung, warum dann den Bereich.
Weil da dazu braucht man natürlich erstmal ein wesentlich tieferes Wissen, damit man das dann auch entsprechend …
Okay, also es war mehr ein Ergebnis sozusagen der fortwährenden Arbeit und nicht so unbedingt jetzt der Wunsch, die Welt vor allen bösen Krankheiten zu retten?
Ach der kommt natürlich dazu, aber man fängt dann natürlich gerade mit Hepatitis C an, also mit einem, wo es dann halt …
Es ist heute noch kein Impfstoff gegen Hepatitis C da, wo man sich natürlich dann dran auch noch die Zähne ausbeißt.
Deshalb muss man immer ein bisschen vorsichtig sein, wenn man nur mit dem Anspruch, die Welt zu retten, das sage ich meinen Studierenden auch immer,
wenn man nur mit dem Anspruch, die Welt zu retten, durch die Tage geistert und plötzlich kriegt man graue Haare und hat festgestellt, man hat immer noch nicht die Welt gerettet,
dass man dann nicht komplett frustriert sich irgendwie zurückzieht.
Also man muss schon noch einen Plan B haben, wenn es mit Weltretten nicht klappt.
Okay, was war denn da der Plan B dann in Berlin?
Na gut, also das war, das hat es eigentlich schlimmer gemacht, es ist dann zur Tuberkulose gegangen, das ist auch so zum Zähne rausbeißen,
weil das ist dann experimentell anders.
Aber das war dann wirklich diese von den Viren im Prinzip zu den Bakterien und die sind natürlich dann komplexer aber auch spannender
und da ging eben auch viel drum, nicht nur den Impfstoff, das ist das eine, aber die Fragestellung, wie schafft das denn so ein Bakterium, ein Pathogen, im Körper so lange zu überleben?
Tuberkulose haben sie ja oft als solche chronisch persistenten Erkrankungen und der Körper schafft es nicht das loszuwerden.
Und das macht hat auch dann wieder die Impfung schwieriger.
Und dieser Erreger spielt dann auch mit dem Immunsystem des Menschen und das ist natürlich dieses Zusammenspiel das zu erkennen und zu erforschen, das macht richtig Spaß.
Aber das hört sich natürlich jetzt immer so toll an, wie wenn Forschung so aussieht, dass man immer das große Zusammenspiel hat.
Faktisch war es so bei meiner Promotion, das erste Dreivierteljahr hat im Prinzip das was ich machen wollte, das war eine DNA-Immunisierung,
es hat ein Dreivierteljahr lang nichts funktioniert, das ist die Realität.
Also das hat sich jetzt alles so angehört wie, dann gehst du ins Labor und zwar nicht Welt retten, aber …
Einmal Heureka und dann war es das.
… jeden Tag bahnbrechende Erkenntnisse, ein Dreivierteljahr hat nichts funktioniert.
Es war wirklich Frust pur.
Dann habe ich was geändert, ich war zu faul genau, diese - das geht vielleicht ein bisschen zu weit - aber im Prinzip ging es drum, T-Zellen aufzureinigen(?)
und man wollte wissen, ob die T-Zellen, das ist ein Teil vom Immunsystem, da gibt es Killer-T-Zellen und ich wollte wissen, ob die durch die Impfung aktiviert werden, so vereinfacht gesagt.
Und man entnimmt die dann dem Tier und reinigt die ein bisschen auf für den Versuch.
Und diese Aufreinigung das war so über Nylonsäulen.
Ich saß jeden Abend vor dem Fernseher und habe diese Nylonsäulen per Hand gestopft, damals konnten wir das nicht einfach so kaufen, sondern das musste …
Nylonsäulen?
Das ist so Nylonwolle, das ist wie so ein Wattebäuschchen, halt aus Nylon und nicht aus Baumwolle.
Und man hat diese Zellsuspension dann im Prinzip dort durchgeleert und hat dann die sauberen Zellen unten drin gehabt.
Wie so ein Filter, wie so ein Sieb?
Genau ja, also schön ordentlich.
Und dann hatte ich keinen Bock, keine Zeit, habe das ohne das gemacht und plötzlich hat es funktioniert.
Das heißt, meine T-Zellen die aktivierten sind da einfach hängen geblieben und die sind nicht rausgekommen, das hat mich ein Dreivierteljahr gekostet.
Und das ist schon schwer frustrierend dann dazwischen.
Also so sieht Forschung halt auch aus, also der Alltag Forschung ist nicht der, dass man jeden Tag ein Paper raushaut.
Und dann hat es funktioniert und dann habe ich dann mit DNA-Impfung als Technik das dort auch etabliert und das war schon sehr spannend, also das muss ich schon sagen.
Das war jetzt der Kampf gegen Tuberkulose?
Genau, allerdings was ich dort gemacht habe, da ging es mehr um, auch da ging es nicht primär drum, dass dieser DNA-Impfstoff, mit dem ich gearbeitet habe,
dass der dann später als Impfstoff zugelassen werden soll, sondern es ging drum, wi rollten einen rekombinanten, also insgesamt das größere Projekt drum herum am MPI war,r wollten einen rekombinanten, also insgesamt das größere Projekt drum herum am MPI war,
dass man einen verbesserten Tuberkulose-Impfstoff bringt, es gibt ja einen Tuberkulose-Impfstoff, allerdings ist der bei bestimmten Tuberkulose-Formen von der Wirksamkeit her schlecht
und die Idee war, dass man diesen Impfstoff verbessert, indem man bestimmte Gene beispielsweise von Mycobacterium Tuberculosis auf diesen Mycobacterium Bovis BCG überträgt.
Da müssen Sie aber erst mal wissen, welche sind denn vielversprechend?
Das heißt, Sie brauchen erst mal eine Technik, wo Sie relativ einfach screenen können, welche von diesen Antigenen, die ich in Tuberkulose habe, aber in BCG nicht habe, welche funktionieren.
Und das ist im Prinzip mein Teil gewesen, ich wollte mit dem Ansatz das etablieren, dass man das mit einer DNA-Immunisierung machen kann, weil die relativ einfach funktioniert.
Das war alles im Tiermodell natürlich, für einen Menschen war das klar, ist das wahrscheinlich ein bisschen schwieriger, aber im Tiermodell geht es sehr einfach und sehr elegant.
Das war also die Idee.
Also es ist nicht immer gleich, dass man, wenn in der Impfstoffforschung ist oder dann impft, dass das immer gleich der Impfstoff ist, der später dann auf den Markt kommt,
sondern da war es eher ein Teil wirklich forschend, damit man die Ergebnisse dann nehmen kann und auf ein anderes System aufsetzen kann.
Das sind dann halt so die klassischen Forschungsentwicklungen, wo jetzt unbedingt ein Pharmaunternehmen, was auf der Suche nach einem Impfstoff ist, nicht primär unbedingt verfolgen würde.
Das will ich jetzt nicht so sagen, also ich glaube, das ist tatsächlich Grundlagenforschung, das würde ein Pharmaunternehmen auch nicht machen können.
Ich war ja selber später in einem Pharmaunternehmen drin, das können Sie nicht machen.
Weil Sie müssen ja, wenn Sie börsennotiert sind müssen Sie ja irgendwie …
Ja, Ergebnisse liefern.
Und Sie wissen, Sie können überhaupt nicht abschätzen, das da rauskommt, in welche Richtung das geht, die Zeithorizonte sind da ganz anders.
… Ergebnisse liefern.
Also das ist tatsächlich eine Grundlagenforschung, die normal ist, dass das an einem Max-Planck-Institut oder so so läuft.
Wenn das dann natürlich zu was kommt, dann ist man Gott sei Dank jetzt schon so weit, dass die auch vom Max-Planck bis Universitäten, dass diese Erfindungen dann entsprechend geschützt werden,
dass die nicht dann vo irgendwelchen Pharmaunternehmen aufgekauft werden und die Uni guckt dann doof aus der Wäsche,von irgendwelchen Pharmaunternehmen aufgekauft werden und die Uni guckt dann doof aus der Wäsche,
sondern dass da auch dann im Prinzip Royalties oder so fließen können, also das ist schon nicht so.
Aber das kann ein Pharmaunternehmen nicht liefern, weil die Zeitspannen ganz anders sind.
Und als Beispiel, wie sieht denn so konkret ein Experiment aus, wenn ich jetzt ein bestimmtes Antigen gegen Tuberkulose testen möchte mit einer DNA-Immunisierung?
Also da muss ich das erstmal klonieren, das ist jetzt nicht so besonders lange, das geht jetzt heute noch schneller wie damals.
Dann muss ich die DNA aufreinigen, damals gab es diese Kits noch nicht, das heißt, das macht man dann über Ultrazentrifugation.
Dann hat man diese Plasmit-DNAPlasmid-DNA, die spritzt man dann.
Dann als Kontrollgruppe hat man immer BCG, nach 120 Tagen kann ich dann die Maus…
Was ist BCG?
Das ist dieser bestehende Impfstoff, Bacillus Calmette-Guérin nennt sich das, Mycrobacterium Bovis Bazillus Calmette-Guérin, BCG abgekürzt.
Das ist der, wo man jetzt als Impfstoff benutzt, das ist eine Kontrolle, die Sie mitnehmen müssen in so einem Experiment.
Also das heißt, 120 Tage später, dann wird die Maus tatsächlich mit Tuberkulose infiziert.
Dann müssen Sie wieder warten, mindestens 90 Tage, dann werden die Organe entnommen, dann wird getestet, wieviel ist da drin, Tuberkulose wächst extrem langsam.
Das haben Sie dann drei Wochen im Brutkasten, bis Sie die Koloniebildung sehen.
Das heißt, so ein Experiment dauert ein halbes Jahr, das ist ein Experiment.
Und das können Sie in einem pharmazeutischen Unternehmen, also ich kenne keine Shareholder, die so lange für ein einzelnes Experiment schon gemütlich warten würden und sagen, macht mal.
Zumindest für eine Krankheit, die jetzt nicht alle betrifft.
Genau, für die Krankheit ist es schwer.
Aber ich will jetzt nicht sagen, das ist nur bei Tuberkulose so ist, sondern ich denke, dass viele Grundlagenforschungen, wo es jetzt nicht direkt darum geht,
ich nehme ein Oberflächenprotein von einem Virus und brauche nur Antikörper, das ist nicht so besonders schwer.
Gott sei Dank ist Corona eher in dieser Kategorie, sage ich mal, wo ich wirklich doch viel mehr verstehen muss, egal bei welcher Erkrankung das ist,
das werde ich in einem Pharmaunternehmen nicht machen können.
Auch HIV zum Beispiel, HIV ist der Markt sicher ganz anders, aber ein HIV-Impfstoff zu entwickeln im Pharmaunternehmen ist unmöglich.
Bleiben wir vielleicht nochmal kurz bei dem Max-Planck-Institut, was Sie da noch weiter beschäftigt hat.
Ich glaube, Salmonellen waren dann auch noch ein Thema?
In Berlin waren die Salmonellen eher so peripher, mit denen habe ich mich direkt selber nicht beschäftigt, ich habe mit Listerien eher gearbeitet, auch als Modellsystem im Tier,
weil die nicht so lange, die Infektionen gehen schneller und Sie sind schneller bei den Resultaten.
Also wenn Sie Grundlagenforschung machen, dass Sie das immer mit Tuberkulose gleich machen, wenn Sie erst mal Ihr System etablieren wollen, ist das nicht so schlau,
weil Sie brauchen ein halbes Jahr für ein Experiment.
Wenn Sie nach einem halben Jahr feststellen, das geht so nicht und Sie müssen dann Ihr neues Experiment aufsetzen, dann werden Sie sehr alt bei den Experimenten.
Dann sind andere Systeme sinnvoller und eines, was im Tiermodell besser geht, sind die Listerien.
Was machen die böses?
Listerien sind, ich dachte eigentlich, von denen redet keiner mehr, ist aber nicht so.
Listerien sind typische Lebensmittelkeime, die in Milchprodukten beispielsweise drin sind.
Wenn Sie schwanger sind und dann eine Listerien-verseuchte Salamiwurst beispielsweise essen, liegt die Todesquote beim Fötus dann bei 50 Prozent.
Es gibt also Leute, letztes Jahr gab es auch wieder einen Serienausbruch, der war relativ groß.
Also es kommt immer wieder vor, dass Listerien-kontaminierte Produkte drin sind und die sind dann relativ für Leute mit schlechtem Immunsystem, das ist ein Problem,
aber gerade Schwangere das ist ein anderes Problem, sind die tatsächlich auch gefährlich für ältere Menschen.
Und Listerien sind jetzt aber nicht eine Erkrankung, wo man sagt, es ist jetzt Priorität Nummer eins, einen Impfstoff gegen Listerien zu entwickeln, deshalb macht das auch keiner.
Also das ist eine bakterielle Infektion, Sie können die im Normalfall, jetzt nicht bei Schwangeren, Sie behandeln die Symptomatik, die diese machen.
Sie können die mit Antibiotika behandeln, also das heißt, da ist es jetzt nicht so wie jetzt bei Corona, dass man zwingend sofort einen Impfstoff braucht.
Was aber bei Listerien das Besondere ist, ist die Art wie diese Listerien Zellen infizieren können.
Die machen was, was sonst eigentlich nur Viren machen, die gehen in Zellen rein, also die können aktiv Zellen infizieren und dadurch brauchen Sie,
um eine Listerien-Infektion loszukriegen nützen Ihnen Antikörper relativ wenig und das ist untypisch bei Bakterien, Sie brauchen wieder diese T-Zellen, diese Killer-Zellen,
ohne die kriegen Sie die Listerien-Infektion nicht los.
Also Antikörper würden einfach auf diese Bakterien gar nicht losgehen oder warum helfen die nicht?
Die Antikörper würden schon auf die losgehen, aber Listerien und Salmonellen und Tuberkulose die infizieren bestimmte Immunzellen und können in diesen Immunzellen überleben.
Und wenn Sie jetzt Antikörper draufpacken, dann kriegen Sie die sogar noch besser in diese Immunzellen rein.
Das heißt, die verkleiden sich sozusagen als Polizisten?
Ja, die lassen sich von den Polizisten fressen und es ist wie wenn Sie in ein Polizeiauto reinkommen und Sie wissen aber, wo die das Bier stehen haben im Polizeiauto und machen dann da drin Rabatz,
So müssen Sie sich das vorstellen.
Also das heißt, Sie holen sich quasi die bösen Buben selber rein.
Ja.
Und das is so ein bisschen das.
Also von der Zellbiologie her ist das natürlich wahnsinnig spannend.
Also auch viele Entwicklungen in der Zellbiologie kamen durch dieses Verständnis, wie diese Gruppe von Pathogenen, insbesondere Listerien, mit Körperzellen interagieren.
Die nehmen nur als Beispiel was die können, wenn die drin sind in der Zelle, dann haben die gar keine eigenen Flagellen, also das sind so diese Fortbewegungsmittel,
die Bakterien haben, eurokaryotische Zellen auch, wenn die auch natürlich anders aussehen.
Diese kleinen Fädchen.
Genau, diese Fädchen, mit denen sie schwimmen können, sondern die können einfach das Aktin in der Zelle der Zelle nehmen, polymerisieren das
und lassen sich durch das fortschieben, also die missbrauchen zelluläre Proteine sogar zur Fortbewegung.
So richtig so Treibstoff sozusagen.
Genau und das ist natürlich Wahnsinn, also ich finde so was wahnsinnig spannend.
Verstehe schon.
Also als Erkrankung ist eine Listeriose, wenn diese Ausbrüche da sind, für die älteren Menschen, Schwangeren natürlich fatal, aber insgesamt als, sagen wir mal,
wenn wir das jetzt von einer Landesperspektive sieht, spielen Listeriosen kaum eine Rolle.
Also man kann die durch Hygiene auch gut in den Griff kriegen, man muss gucken, dass die Milchprodukte sauber sind.
Jetzt sitzen wir ja heute in Würzburg, da hat Sie dann später alles hingetrieben.
Genau.
Und dann ging es um Krebs.
Also von wegen, also irgendwie habe ich so, wenn Sie mich so angucken, habe ich immer das Gefühl, warum denn?
Frage ich mich irgendwie auch.
Weil es ist immer so, ich habe so das Gefühl, so im Nachhinein, man wollte es immer ein bisschen schwerer haben.
Also so Hepatitis C war schon für einen Impfstoff schwer genug, dann diese Tuberkulose ist auch wieder was und jetzt kommen wir in Richtung Tumorimpfung und Richtung Tumorimmunologie.
Und das ist dann natürlich nochmal wieder so eine andere Geschichte.
Das ist ein Begriff, der mir in gewisser Hinsicht neu ist, also dass man gegen Krebs auch wirklich Immunität entwickelt, ist das ein normales Ding
oder ist das etwas, was man erst seit kürzerem weiß oder geht das noch gar nicht und man will es herstellen?
Was ist da der Stand der Dinge?
Das ist eine Wellenbewegung.
Also man hatte vor 20-30 Jahren hatte man gedacht, das Immunsystem Krebs, das ist wahnsinnig wichtig, man hat alles reingeschmissen und dann kamen einige Misserfolge.
Heute ist es aber tatsächlich anerkannt, dass das Immunsystem bei Krebs eine ganz große Rolle spielt.
Also das heißt, ein Tumor, wenn man sich den anschaut, besteht nicht einfach nur aus Krebszellen, sondern da sind viele andere Zellen auch drin.
Ganz normale Zellen.
Und beispielsweise beim Brustkrebs sind fast 50 Prozent der Zellen, die im Tumor drin sind, Makrophagen, das sind eigentlich Immunzellen.
Und das sind jetzt keine Krebsmakrophagen, also die irgendeine Mutation haben, das sind ganz normale Makrophagen, die sind aber durch den Tumor ein bisschen umprogrammiert worden.
Das sind dann also nicht mehr die coolen Makrophagen, die irgendwelche bösen Bakterien wegräumen, sondern die machen ganz was anderes.
Und diese Makrophagen beispielsweise sind so umprogrammiert, dass die das Gefäßwachstum anregen können, auf das der Tumor angewiesen ist.
Wenn Sie diese Makrophagen aus dem Brusttumor wegnehmen, dann steht der Tumor, kann der nicht mehr weiter wachsen.
Also das heißt, das ist das eine, die Immunzellen waren teilweise durch den Tumormissbrauch, kann man schon sagen, aber andernfalls gibt es eben Zellen,
die wenn man sie lässt den Tumor auch bekämpfen können.
Und das ist jetzt, das war damals, als ich in diese Impfstoff, Tumorimpfung gewechselt habe, wobei die Arbeitsgruppe, die ich da geleitet habe in Würzburg,
Aber wenn man jetzt von der Impfstoffschiene gehen, war schon immer klar, dass Tumorzellen potenzielle Angriffspunkte sind für das Immunsystem.
Aber es war auch klar, dass ein Tumor immer versucht, das Immunsystem kleinzuhalten.
Das heißt, die Frage ist zum einen, wie kann ich T-Zellen oder wie kann ich eine Immunantwort induziert, die gegen den Tumor gerichtet ist spezifisch
und zum anderen, wie kann ich es schaffen, dass die gegen den Tumor auch wirklich was tun können?
Das sind die zwei Sachen, auch da nützen mir Antikörper bei einer Tumorantwort nützen mir Antikörper relativ wenig.
Da braucht man auch wieder diese zelluläre Antwort und die zu induzieren ist einfach schwieriger, das ist das Problem.
Also das war dann hier an der Universität Würzburg und das war dann sozusagen für die nächsten Jahre der Bereich, in dem man geforscht hat,
aber auch da ging es quasi schon um Impfstoffe?
Genau, das waren zwei Aspekte, und da sin die Salmonellen jetzt auch ins Boot gekommen.
Hingekommen, man muss vielleicht auch nochmal sagen, wie bin ich eigentlich hierhin gekommen?
Naja ich glaube, das darf ich keinem erzählen.
Also das war halt, eigentlich ging es um eine Ausgründung der Leiter von dem Institut medizinische Strahlenkunde und Zellforschung Professor Rapp,
der hat einen Vortrag gehalten bei uns in Berlin und hat mich dann danach gefragt, also nicht direkt nach dem Vortrag, sondern zwei Tage später,
ob ich mir vorstellen könnte, nach Würzburg zu kommen, weil die auch eine Firma ausgründen wollen und dass ich dann in diese Firma reingehe,
die einen bakteriellen Tumorimpfstoff propagieren, und zwar auf Salmonellenbasis.
Und das war zusammen mit der Mikrobiologie hier in Würzburg.
Das konnte ich mir sehr gut vorstellen und bin dann hingekommen, allerdings mit der Ausgründung das hat dann noch sehr sehr lange gedauert, ein Weilchen,
um es vorsichtig zu formulieren, das heißt, man musste doch noch einiges machen an diesem Salmonellenimpfstoff, dass der besser funktioniert.
Und wir haben dann im Laufe der Zeit eben auch ein zweites Standbein aufgebaut und haben noch einen Tumortargeting mit Bakterien gemacht,
also die Bakterien in den Tumor zu bringen.
Aber das ist tatsächlich ein klassischer Impfstoff, in dem Fall war die Idee, dass man Salmonellen nimmt und diese Salmonellen rekombinant ein Tumorantigen herstellen lässt.
In dem Fall haben wir angefangen oder das mit prostataspezifischem Antigen gemacht, das bei Prostatatumor im Prinzip hochreguliert wird, es verstärkt hergestellt wird
und somit ein potenzielles Zielmolekül ist.
Und der Vorteil, wenn Sie so einen Salmonellenimpfstoff nehmen, ist, dass Sie den auch oral applizieren können.
Also Sie können den einfach oral geben, Sie müssen den nicht spritzen oder irgendwas.
Und wir haben dann eben dort in Würzburg mit Kollegen, das ist immer wir, also das bin nicht ich, sondern da kam schon relativ viel von dem Labor von Göbel rein.
Die haben gezeigt, dass es ein System gibt, wie man diese Antigene aus der Zelle rausbringt, ein sogenanntes Typ 1 Sekretionssystem.
Und die haben mit dem Kollegen Genchev, da war der ganz wesentlich beteiligt, der konnte dann zeigen, dass, wenn man ein , da war der ganz wesentlich beteiligt, der konnte dann zeigen, dass, wenn man ein Adjuvanzgen an das ransetzt,Adjuvansgen an das ransetzt,
dass das dann eine verstärkte CD8 Antwort gibt.
Was ist ein Adjuvanz?
Also wenn Sie jetzt ein Protein nehmen würden, einfach ein Protein, das ist jetzt ein Protein, ein Virusprotein, zum Beispiel das Hüllprotein.
Und Sie spritzen das einfach so rein, dann passiert eigentlich nichts.
aber wenn Sie Pech haben, passiert genau das Gegenteil, Sie werden gegen das abgehärtet.
Wenn Sie das essen, ist es noch schlimmer.
Weil, wenn wir gegen alles reagieren würden, was wir jemals aufnehmen, dann würden Sie nicht froh.
Weil es eine Überreaktion wäre?
Ja, der Körper muss sich ja schützen, dass er gegen alles, was nicht körpereigen ist, eine Immunantwort macht.
Und das, was Sie essen, Sie sehen, die meisten Weizenproteine oder so die haben mit dem Körper vom Menschen wenig zu tun.
Aber wenn das oral kommt, dann muss das dem Immunsystem gesagt werden, lass mal, ist okay.
Passt schon.
Passt schon. Sobald das dann in das System reingeht, ist das was anderes.
Aber selbst wenn Sie so spritzen, dann müssen Zellen vom Immunsystem erst mal zusätzlich aktiviert werden, dass die anfangen ihren Job zu machen.
Sonst wäre das relativ heikel, weil jedesmal, wenn Sie sich irgendwie nur schneiden und da irgendein bisschen Dreck dran ist und Sie dann eine massive Immunantwort gegen den Dreck machen,
der Ihnen ja nichts tut eigentlich, dann haben Sie ein Problem.
Also das ist diese Regulierung und deshalb braucht man, wenn man einen Impfstoff hat, haben praktisch alle Impfstoffe, die Sie jetzt haben, die auf Totimpfstoffen beruhen
oder auf Rekombinantenimpfstoffen beruhen, wo Sie nur Proteine drin haben, die brauchen Wirkverstärker, das nennt sich ein Adjuvant.
Und wir haben das im Prinzip genetisch an dieses PSA, das PSA ist dieses Prostata-spezifische Antigen, das ist also dieses Tumorarntigen von dem Prostatakrebs,
an das haben wir die B-Einheint von dem Choleratoxin hinfusionierthin fusioniert genetisch und das verstärkt die Wirkung und das kann das auch noch geschickt in einem bestimmten Weg reinshufflen,
dass wir noch eine verbesserte Antwort haben von diesen Killerzellen.
Das hat funktioniert?
Das hat funktioniert.
Das heißt, es gibt einen Impfstoff gegen Prostatakrebs?
Ha, der ist nicht auf dem Markt.
Also das heißt, wir haben den Impfstoff dann an eine Pharmafirma, naja verkauft würde ich es jetzt nicht nennen, das hört sich so, an ob man Millionen umgesetzt hat, das ist Phase 1.
Also das war noch vor Phase 1, das heißt wert ist die Sache, das Zeug dann erst begrenzt was.
Also von einem 3-Phasen-Modell.
Genau. Das heißt, noch vor dieser klinischen Phase und ich bin mit dem Impfstoff dann eigentlich in diese pharmazeutische Firma mitgegangen.
Und wir haben dort dann diese präklinische Entwicklung und dann waren wir kurz vor Phase 1 und dann haben die Investoren beschlossen, weil die anderen Produkte waren eigentlich ganz anders gelagert, das war so ein Exotenprodukt,
da sind ein paar Mal Chefs abgelöst worden und irgendwann haben dann die Boards gesagt, das Projekt bleibt dann jetzt erst mal liegen und wir nicht mehr weitergemacht.
Aber jetzt seit zwei Jahren ist eine Firma in New York, Socium Therapeutics, die haben das jetzt wieder reingeholt und die wollen das wieder weiterentwickeln.
Also es ist noch, das hat mich sehr gefreut natürlich und überrascht, also es ist nicht ganz tot, aber das ist natürlich dann nunmal so, wenn Sie in der pharmazeutischen Industrie sind und selbst wenn Sie in einem börsennotierten Unternehmen sind,
konkurrieren Sie mit jeder Entwicklung, mit anderen Entwicklungen auch und dann gibt es natürlich Entscheidungen, dass man sagt, mach ich mit dem weiter oder nicht?
Und auch wenn ich natürlich das, wenn ich da viele Tränen geweint habe, wenn das Produkt eingestellt wird, weil ich glaube, das hat wirklich eine gute Perspektive, muss man doch verstehen von Investorensicht, irgendjemand muss das ja bezahlen.
Und so eine Entwicklung in einem pharmazeutischen Bereich normalerweise läuft über zehn Jahre.
Und Sie verbrennen über die zehn Jahre mit einer klinischen Entwicklung 200-300 Millionen Euro.
Und das ist dann natürlich nicht Ihr Geld, das muss Ihnen ja irgendjemand geben und da muss man dann natürlich schon verstehen, dass die Leute das abwägen, das ist so.
Ja.
Das ist dann zwar frustrierend, aber mit dem muss man umgehen können.
Das ist dann auch so ein Punkt, sind wir wieder beim Thema Welt retten, da hätten wir vielleicht die Leute vor Prostatakrebs retten können,
aber natürlich muss das dann erst mal durch die ganzen Entwicklungen durchgezogen werden.
Und es gibt natürlich viele vielversprechende Ansätze, das darf man nicht vergessen.
Also im Endeffekt muss ich das dann nachher beweisen, wenn ich durch Phase 3 durch bin und das klappt dann auch da, dann kann man sagen, okay.
Vorher ist das einfach ein vielversprechender Ansatz, mehr nicht.
Und vielversprechende Ansätze gibt es in vielen Bereichen sozusagen?
Also natürlich gibt es die nicht noch und nöcher.
Ich meine, es ist ja immer, sagen wir mal, es gibt natürlich Ansätze, die sind eigentlich genau gleich wie andere Ansätze.
Das ist dann halt, natürlich wenn ich jetzt gegen einen Virus, der eine normale Virusklasse ist, einen Impfstoff entwickle, dann brauche ich Antiköper, die Hüllproteine neutralisieren, fertig.
Also das ist ja nichts komplett neues.
Aber wenn ich jetzt einen Tumorimpfstoff mache, muss ich zelluläre Antworten induzieren, da reichen mir Antikörper wieder nicht.
Und dann muss ich dann überlegen, wie kann ich das optimal machen?
Und da ist es natürlich sehr sehr sinnvoll, dass neue Ansätze, die jetzt DNA, RNA, was auch immer, dass man die wirklich dann auch entwickelt,
Es gibt so einen Spruch, wenn Sie eine Maus sind und Krebs haben, dann können wir Ihnen helfen.
Menschen dauern bisschen länger.
Menschen dauern bisschen länger ja.
Ja, ich meine, das ist natürlich eine interessante Abwägung immer und ich glaube, dass auch die öffentliche Wahrnehmung dieses Komplexes Pharmainvestionenen, Forschung etc.
was geht theoretisch, was wird dann letztlich praktisch gemacht, ist schwer nachzuvollziehen, gerade weil eben, wie Sie ja schon ausführt haben,
diese Entwicklungszyklen Operativer Service unglaublich lang sind.
Und ich meine, welcher Manager eines großen Unternehmens würde da nicht vorsichtig vorgehen, wenn man es wirklich mit solchen Zeiträumen zu tun?
Zehn Jahre ist ja auch ein Zeitraum, wo man sich vielleicht schon selber gar nicht mehr in irgendeinem Unternehmen sieht, geschweige denn, dass man sich in der Lage sieht,
auch die gesamtwirtschaftliche Entwicklung in irgendeiner Form abzuschätzen, wer kann das schon?
Kaum jemand und von daher ist es ein Risikospiel natürlich, wo man in gewisser Hinsicht Sicherheiten haben will.
Und vielleicht und jetzt kommen wir so langsam auf einen interessanten Bereich, ist es ja auch so eine grundsätzliche Frage, wie sehr werden Impfstoffe überhaupt auch gewünscht?
Wie sehr werden Impfstoffe auch akzeptiert?
Selbst wenn man einen hätte, würden Leute ihn anwenden wollen, würde er empfohlen werden?
Gibt es Widerstand dagegen, so etwas überhaupt vielleicht auch an Kinder schon anzuwenden, die Diskussion haben wir ja am laufenden Meter.
Sie haben ja dann quasi dadurch auch so ein bisschen die Perspektive vielleicht nicht geändert, aber erweitert.
Dass man sozusagen aus diesem Forschungsbereich, aus dieser Forschungsperspektive reinkommt in die wirtschaftlich getriebene Welt.
Wie ist denn so Ihre Wahrnehmung, welchen Status dieses, wie soll man das denn nennen, diese Impfstoffwelt in der Gesellschaft hatte?
Und wie hat es sich jetzt vielleicht in diesem Jahr verändert?
Jetzt muss ich erstmal vorab sagen, wir reden jetzt seit einer halben Stunde und Sie sagen, jetzt kommen wir endlich in einen interessanten Bereich.
Wir sind die ganze Zeit im interessanten Bereich.
Jetzt war alles so langweilig.
Das habe ich nicht gesagt, es wird noch interessanter.
Alles gut.
Ja, wie ist die Wahrnehmung.
Also es ist schwer.
Also ich meine, wenn man Jahre im Impfstoffbereich tätig war und immunologisch tätig war,
und ich habe das ja auch erklärt, wenn man in die Tiefe reingeht und diese Einblicke kennt,
es ist schon teilweise schwer zu ertragen, sage ich fast schon, wenn man dann mal den Fernseher anschaltet,
und dann ein, sagen wir mal, ein, ich würde schon fast sagen, ein militanter Impfstoffgegner dann da vor einem auftritt,
der mit vollster Überzeugung Ihnen erzählt, das Virus gibt es nicht, das Immunsystem gibt es nicht und ein Impfstoff ist, weiß nicht, Bill Gates…
… Teil einer Weltverschwörung.
Und die glauben das auch noch.
Also das ist ja nicht nur, weil er das macht, weil er irgendwie …
Die wollen es glauben, ja.
Und es ist schon, ich muss sagen, es ist hart.
Also wenn man wirklich aus dem Bereich ist und wirklich Jahre dran geforscht hat und den Kenntnisstand hat und natürlich auch die Risiken,Nutzen und so weiter kennt,
also das ist ja nicht so, dass ein Impfstoffforscher vollkommen blauäugig für alles dann sagt, Impfstoff ist immer super oder irgendwie.
Es ist echt schwer, also das ist ganz schwer.
Mit den Leuten, vielleicht erst mal, es ist, was ich auch festgestellt habe, ich habe ja selber Kinder und die sind natürlich alle geimpft.
Ich bin auch jedes Jahr grippegeimpft, nicht weil ich mir zur Risikogruppe rechne, dieses Jahr habe ich noch nicht geimpft, weil ich nicht wusste, wieviel da ist,
deshalb will man erstmal gucken, dass die Risikogruppen genug Impfstoff kriegen, gerade dieses Jahr.
Ich habe zwar keine Angst, an der Grippe zu sterben, aber ich habe keine Lust, anderthalb Wochen flachzuliegen, ganz einfach.
Und ich fahre immer ICE, das heißt also, ich fahre mit Bahncard100 immer zum Arbeiten, das heißt, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass man sich mal was fängt, ist nicht so gering.
Also das heißt, für mich selber ist es ganz normal, dass ich diese Impfstoffe, die entwickelt wurden, auch an mir anwende bzw. an meinen Kindern, weil die Impfstoffe ein großer Segen sind.
Jetzt ist es aber so, dass in der Gesellschaft, ich weiß jetzt nicht wieviel Prozent das sind, aber sicher 20 Prozent der Menschen sehr sehr kritisch sind.
Und die sind lustigerweise genau eigentlich Leute, die jetzt nicht aus einem bildungsfernen Bereich kommen, sondern die eher sogar eher Akademikerschicht sind.
Auch im eigenen Bekanntenkreis ist es so, also wenn Sie dann so Homöopthiefreaks mit Soziologiestudium…
Also ich habe versucht, anfänglich immer mit den Leuten halt zu reden, weil ich dachte, naja vielleicht …
… Mangel an Informationen.
Aber was ich festgestellt habe, die hören gar nicht zu, mache ich jetzt nicht mehr.
Also das erschreckende ist, es lohnt sich einfach nicht.
Also wenn Sie jetzt einen Impfstoffgegner haben, der schon mit Blutunterlaufenen Augen zu einem kommt …
Ich war einmal, da kam einer zu mir und der sagt, er freut sich jetzt richtig, dass er mit mir reden kann, aus dieser bösen Industrie kommend, weil er mich dann überzeugen kann, dass das eigentlich alles Quatsch war.
Und das war, ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, ein Realschullehrer für Sport und Englisch oder irgendsowas.
Aber da fragt man sich, …
Ja und da habe ich festgestellt, das bringt nichts.
Diese Entwicklung ist wirklich, ich halte das für ganz problematisch, aber ich glaube, das kommt nicht aus so einer, ich glaube, das ist Egoismus einfach.
Also ich glaube, unsere Gesellschaft kann es sich leisten, relativ egoistisch zu sein, weil die Leute nur auf sich schauen.
Weil beim Impfstoff ist das eine, dass ich mich selber schütze, aber beim Impfstoff ist es auch, dass ich Nebenwirkungen, die es natürlich bei Impfstoffen gibt, das leugnet ja keiner ab,
schwere anaphylaktische Reaktionen haben Sie bei allen Impfstoffen mit einer Frequenz von 1:3000000 oder irgendwas
und das ist natürlich eine ganz dramatische Nebenwirkung, die Sie dann möglicherweise auch Intensivstation, Kortison, was weiß ich was, also das ist jetzt kein Pillepalle, das haben Sie.
Aber ich schütze natürlich auch andere, die ich nicht impfen kann, Masern beispielsweise.
Masernimpfstoff kann ich erst mit einem Jahr geben, das kann ich vorher nicht geben.
Das problematische sind bei Masern aber vor allem dann die Kleinstkinder mit einem halben Jahr, die kann ich mit einer Impfung gar nicht schützen,
die kann ich nur über Herdenimmunität schützen, die ich natürlich über eine Impfung machen will und nicht über eine Infektion machen will.
Und das heißt, das begreifen die Leute gar nicht, dass ich also die schwächsten da damit schütze und das ist heute eigentlich nicht mehr en vogue.
Also man denkt immer nur an sich und sagt, naja da könnte eine Nebenwirkung kommen und deswegen mache ich das nicht.
Und dann habe ich so das Gefühl, manche lügen sich dann irgendsoein System in der Tasche, wie man das auch noch besser begründen kann, weil Egoismus hört sich halt doof an.
Aber ich muss einfach strak sagen, in meinen Augen ist das zu 80 Prozent Egoismus.
Und das ist traurig, das ist einfach so.
Und ich komme jetzt auf das Corona zurück, ich habe eigentlich am Anfang gedacht, naja jetzt haben wir plötzlich eine Epidemie,
wo es mal wieder zeigt, dass ein Impfstoff dort eigentlich die Rettung ist.
Wenn ich jetzt mit dem Impfstoff meine 60-70 Prozent Immunität hinkriege, dann habe ich meinen Herdenschutz bei dieser R-Zahl von 3 und dann ist alles gut.
Und dann dachte ich, also das müsste eigentlich die Leute überzeugen.
Und vollkommen erstaunt sieht man, dass es bei manchen Leuten immer noch verstärkt die ablehnen.
Allerdings glaube ich auch, dass wir das in Deutschland exklusiv haben das Problem, also nicht ganz exklusiv.
Also es hat, sagen wir mal, in Ländern auf der Entwicklungsstufe von Deutschland bei anderen Ländern auch, manchmal mehr und manchmal weniger extrem,
aber Länder, die deutlich unter der Entwicklungsstufe stehen, ist das eben nicht so.
Und da, wenn ich mir jetzt das anschaue bei uns in Cleve, mein Studiengang Bioengineering, wir haben ungefähr so 500 Studierende insgesamt jetzt so drin über die Jahre,
mit 60 Prozent internationalen Studierenden, der ist englischsprachig der Studiengang,
es gibt nicht viele Bachelorstudiengänge, die englischsprachig sind, aus 65 Nationen.
Und das ist natürlich wahnsinnig spannend, gerade so Fragen mal zu diskutieren mit denen.
Und das sind ja alles trotzdem alles Studierende, das heißt, die sind natürlich akademisch gebildet,
die spiegeln jetzt nicht unbedingt den Bevölkerungsquerschnitt von jedem Land wider,
aber es ist schon erstaunlich, dass für die es vollkommen unbegreiflich ist, wie in einem entwickelten Land wie Deutschland,
also für die meisten aus solchen Ländern, dass man dann Impfstoffe ablehnt, oder dass 20 Prozent der Bevölkerung Impfstoffe ablehnt, das ist schon erstaunlich zu sehen.
Ich habe mich vor einiger Zeit mich mal in so ein paar Politikerreden ungefähr von vor 100 Jahren gestoßen,
wie so Ansprachen ans Volk so waren und wie so insbesondere eben so in den 20er/30er und auch noch 40er Jahre auf Wissenschaft geblickt wurde.
Und in gewisser Hinsicht war ja Wissenschaft damals auch noch neu.
Also neu im Sinne von, dass es dieses Berufsbild des Wissenschaftlers/der Wissenschaftlerin gibt,
dass es entsprechende Strukturen gibt, die ja dann überhaupt auch langsam erst aufgebaut wurden,
wie den Stifterverband und viele andere Dinge auch, dass sagen wir mal auch dieses ganze Konzept eines vernetzten Arbeitens der wissenschaftlichen Methode etc. alles erst mal so eine Präsenz bekam,
und man sich so um Zug um Zug auch, glaube ich, in der Wahrnehmung der Gesellschaft verabschiedet hat von diesen Universalgelehrten,
die halt auch oft dann mal daneben lagen und wo die Philosophen auch noch alle so ihre Deutungshoheiten noch absteckten.
Und in diesen Ansprachen fand sich dann eben so eine große Anerkennung für den Fortschritt da.
Denn der Fortschritt war ja sichtbar, nachhaltig, vielfältig, nicht nur jetzt in Bereichen wie, was weiß ich, Energieversorgung, es gab Strom
oder die Erfindung der Kommunikation, Telefon, Radio, all diese ganzen Dinge, späterFernsehen noch mit dazu,
das waren ja alles für sich genommen kleine Weltwunder.
Aber dann eben auch die konsequente Abschaffung von Krankheiten, die bis dahin ja totaler Terror waren.
Kinderlähmung das habe ich selbst noch mitbekommen, wie in den 70er Jahren eigentlich, glaube ich, über einen Zeitraum von zehn Jahren, dass das Problem verschwand.
Eliminiert.
Eliminiert wurde durch eine entsprechend öffentliche Kampagne.
Das heißt, ich würde sagen, so noch bis in die 80er/90er Jahre rein gab es einfach noch dieses Echo, dieses Gedächtnis,
aber ich glaube, dass wir mittlerweile eben uns in gewisser Hinsicht daran gewöhnt haben, dass alles toll ist.
Dass da sozusagen keine unmittelbare Bedrohung mehr von Seuchen ausgeht.
Und dass das vielleicht bei manchen Leuten dann einfach so verfangen hat, ja wieso, habe ich noch nie was von gehört.
Ja Masern hat doch keiner, was wollt ihr mir denn eigentlich erzählen?
Ist schwierig.
Ja, also dazu kommt natürlich jetzt noch dieses neue Phänomen der schnellfließenden Informationen und der virtualisierten Stammtische, die halt einfach diese Gerüchteküche vorantreiben.
Und ich glaube, was auch noch mit reinspielt ist so dann wiederum auch so eine Verlorenheit des Individuums, die sich dann eben schon auch einer komplexen Welt gegenüber sehen,
wo eigentlich alles, mit dem wir so täglich zu tun haben, wenn man da auch nur so ein bisschen reinfragt, gleich so kompliziert und vielschichtig ist,
dass man es halt einfach auch gar nicht mehr versteht und so ein gewisser Wunsch besteht, selber irgendwie einfach mal eine Meinung haben zu können,
einen Glauben zu haben, wie wohl alles ist und manche müssen sich dann eben auch absondern und einfach alles mal genau anders sehen,
weil sie jetzt erzählt bekommen haben, dass sie jetzt dadurch irgendeine besondere tiefe Erkenntnis haben, die wahrscheinlich so gar keine ist.
Also ich glaube vielleicht, um das mal aufgreifen, ich glaube natürlich ist es so, heutzutage verstärkt sich das natürlich durch diese Informationsblasen,
die die Leute haben, wenn die in ihren sozialen Netzwerken im Prinzip immer nur selbstverstärkt diese Gedanken haben.
Das gab es natürlich vorher auch schon und natürlich ist es so, man kann natürlich so ein bisschen die Leute auch verstehen,
dass man durchaus auch kritisch auf Aussagen von Wissenschaft gucken darf, das ist keine Frage,
weil wenn Sie jetzt diese optimistischen 40er/50er/60er Jahre anschauen, ich weiß noch selber, wenn man die Bücher angeschaut hat,
was Kernkraft betrifft, also da hat Ihnen jeder Wissenschaftler erklärt, das ist das tollste der Welt.
Und das eine ist, wissenschaftlich gesehen gar keine Frage, ich kann durch Kernspaltung wahnsinnig viel Energie rausholen.
Allerdings hat eine Wissenschaft immer auch eine gesellschaftliche Seite und man muss überlegen, will ich das oder will ich das nicht?
Also das heißt, man kann Kernkraft ablehnen, obwohl diese Form der Energiegewinnung von der Effizienz her ganz toll ist, von der wissenschaftlichen Seite.
Aber es gibt natürlich auch den radioaktiven Dreck oder das Zeug fliegt einem um die Ohren oder irgendwas, das ist nun mal da und das Risiko ist da und dann muss ich das abwägen, ist das gut oder schlecht.
Was für mich aber jetzt neu ist, dass dieses Problem eben nicht nur diese gesellschaftlichen Konsequenzen abgreift, was eine Gesellschaft machen muss,
das kann nicht sein, dass Wissenschaftler, dass man ein technokratisches Regime irgendwie hat, wo Wissenschaftler dann entscheiden, machen wir das oder machen wir das nicht?
Das muss die Gesellschaft entscheiden.
Und Deutschland fand ich immer noch super und faszinierend, in Deutschland die Gesellschaft hat entschieden, dass wir keine Kernkraft wollen.
Und das ist nicht ein Wissenschaftler, der das entschieden hat, da gab es auch viele, die gesagt haben, seid ihr blöd?
Sondern das hat die Gesellschaft entschieden.
Und jetzt müssen wir das auch irgendwie umsetzen und es wäre nee eigene Baustelle, ob wir das gut oder schlecht machen,
aber was ich erstaunlich finde ist, damals hat keiner dran gezweifelt, dass das Grundprinzip der Kernspaltung, dass aus der Kernspaltung viel Energie frei wird.
Jetzt beim Impfen ist es so, dass es nicht drum geht, will ich jetzt …
man kann jetzt bei einzelnen Impfstoffen kann man als Gesellschaft überlegen, will ich eine Impfung empfehlen bei einer Erkrankung XY,
wo ich weiß die kann ich nicht ausrotten, weil da gibt es ein Tierreservoir, es gibt eine bestimmte Anzahl an Nebenwirkungen,
die Erkrankung ist nicht groß gefährlich, das ist jetzt einfach mal hypothetisch und dann kann ich entscheiden, nein so eine Impfung brauchen wir nicht.
Aber es ist jetzt so, dass bei den meisten Impfgegnern es nicht drum geht um diese Abwägung, sondern es geht drum,
dass die ablehnen, was das Grund wirkt, was das Grundprinzip von einer Impfung ist, dass ich Antikörper induziere, die gegen den Virus binden, die dann den Eintritt neutralisieren.
Das ist ungefähr wie wenn ich sage, eine Kernspaltung gibt es gar nicht, da kann ich keine Energie machen.
Und das ist das problematische.
Und dass es jetzt geschafft wurde durch diese ganzen Fake-News, dass man es geschafft hat, ich weiß gar nicht wer,
aber dass es jetzt im Prinzip so da ist, dass diese Meinung, naja eine Impfung kann gar nicht funktionieren, weil eigentlich gibt es kein Immunsystem, so in Anführungszeichen,
jetzt fast schon gleichwertig mit dem Wissen von einem Wissenschaftler gesetzt wird und das finde ich das erschreckende.
Also das ist jetzt nicht mehr die gesellschaftliche Abwägung, sondern ich habe da irgendsoeine Meinung, so von wegen, eine Impfung ist ja Quatsch, weil den Virus gibt es gar nicht,
versus die wissenschaftliche Haltung, weil es einfach Fakten sind.
Und das ist wirklich ganz erstaunlich.
Naja ist die Frage, wer das sozusagen gleich hält, am Ende haben wir, glaube ich, auch ein mediales Problem, weil es oft mit so, ja hier haben wir jemanden,
der hat verstanden wie es funktioniert und es irgendwie 50 Jahre studiert und angewendet so, aber jetzt haben wir auch noch jemanden gefunden, der ist einfach dagegen.
So und jetzt müssen wir hier also diese Balanced Arguments haben, was natürlich überhaupt nicht balanciert ist.
Das haben wir ja auch schon im Bereich des Umweltschutzes mehrfach gesehen.
Genau.
Ja, es ist wirklich schwierig, ich grüble auch gerade, ob sich da vielleicht in den 80er Jahren gerade auch mit dieser Umweltgegenbewegung ein bisschen was verändert hat.
Weil es gibt ja auch so eine diffuse Grundangst gegenüber Gentechnologie, weil es halt an so einen Punkt ansetzt, den wir so ein bisschen als unsere eigene Ursuppe, nicht ganz zu unrecht, ansehen.
Also dass man sozusagen an die Natur des Menschen geht und die Wissenschaft dadurch ja vielleicht für manche auch so ein wenig infrage stellt,
ob wir quasi noch so eigenständige geistige Wesen sind, dass man an der Stelle überhaupt gar nicht mehr auf so einer atomaren Ebene auseinandergenommen werden will.
Ich will es jetzt gar nicht weiter deuten, aber es scheint auf jeden Fall eine sehr komplexe Gemengelage zu sein, die viel auch mit dem Selbstverständnis von Leuten zu tun hat.
Ich meine, das ist ja auch legitim.
Also als Beispiel Gentechnik, was natürlich so eine Coretechnologie in der Biotechnologie ist,
Biotechnologie ist nicht gleich Gentechnik, aber natürlich die Methode CRISPR/Cas dieses Jahr Nobelpreis, also das ist natürlich ein wichtiger Baustein.
Aber wenn ich jetzt in Deutschland mir das anschaue, gentechnisch modifizierte Pflanzen beispielsweise, das ist ja hier in Deutschland ein absolute NoGo.
Und ich glaube, wenn Sie jetzt durch eine Einkaufsstraße laufen und willkürlich hundert Leute holen, dann werden 99 ausbrüllen, auf gar keinen Fall.
Und das ist was, da kann man tatsächlich sagen, als Gesellschaft kann man sagen, ich für unsere Gesellschaft sage, wollen wir nicht.
Also das ist ja was, was jetzt nicht, ob das gut oder schlecht ist sei mal dahingestellt, aber eine Gesellschaft kann so was entscheiden.
Das Problem ist aber auch da wieder bei Gentechnik, das ist ja nicht so nach dem Motto, wir wollen das nicht, sondern das ist gefährlich.
Also wenn ich das esse, dann fallen mir die Haare aus.
Sie schauen mich an, ich habe …
Ich habe nichts gesagt.
Naja, ist gut, dass hier keine Kamera aufgebaut ist.
Das ist die Kraft des Podcasts.
Aber das ist einfach falsch.
Also wenn das so wäre, dann müsste in den Vereinigten Staaten müsste im Prinzip die Bevölkerung quasi schon komplett dezimiert sein.
Also das heißt, das Risiko ist nicht da und man darf als Gesellschaft immer noch frei entscheiden, will ich das, will ich nicht.
Und die Wissenschaft hat da auch eine gewisse Bringschuld, Argumente zu bringen, warum das durchaus Sinn macht.
Aber das dann so auf diese Schiene zu bringen, wo dann plötzlich die Meinung pseudowissenschaftlich wird,
was sie einfach nicht ist, das geht nicht, das ist ein großes Problem.
Und das führt auch dazu, dass die Leute nicht mehr miteinander reden können, weil in den USA haben die sich anders entschieden.
Das ist nicht nur weil Monsanto das reingedrückt hat, sondern ich glaube, der Getreidebaron in Texas hat da überhaupt gar kein Problem damit.
Wenn Sie zu dem jetzt kommen und sagen, du bist des Teufels, dann wird er sagen, wieso und bringt Ihnen 20 Argumente und dann müssen Sie erst mal gegen den argumentieren.
Das schaffen Sie so einfach nicht.
Also das hat natürlich auch Vorteile, mit CRISPR/Cas sind wir jetzt sowieso auf anderen Baustellen.
Es gibt natürlich auch Nachteile, die es zu diskutieren gibt.
Aber wenn Sie dann mit den Leuten plötzlich gar nicht mehr reden, weil Sie die grundsätzlich für doof halten,
haben wir ein echtes Problem, weil das bringt keinen weiter und da haben wir die Polarisierung.
Und das ist, diese Polarisierung verstärkt sich, wenn Sie Meinung dann eben mit Wissenschaft gleichsetzen, das ist ein echtes Problem.
Ja ist eh ganz lustig, was man dann eigentlich sozusagen auch als Technologie wahrnimmt.
Also in gewisser Hinsicht, ich meine, nahezu keine Pflanze, die wir heute im Supermarkt kaufen als Lebensmittel, gab es vor 300 Jahren in der Form.
Es ist alles quasi durch Gentechnologie entwickelt worden, nur dass die Anwendung der Technologie noch anders aussah.
Es war halt einfach die Auswahl, das gezielte Herbeiführen bestimmter Ausprägungen einer Pflanze, indem man halt immer geschaut hat, okay hier entwickelt es sich so,
hier entwickelt es sich so, heute sind die Werkzeuge ein bisschen anders, aber letzten Endes wird ja immer noch dasselbe Ziel verfolgt.
Jetzt müssen wir aber doch mal auf den aktuellen Elefanten im Raum zu sprechen kommen, es ist Oktober 2020
und wir laufen immer noch alle mit Masken rum und sind mehr oder weniger vorsichtig, weil eben dieses Corona-Virus, wie es jetzt genannt wird,
also genau das SARS-CoV-2-Virus über uns gekommen ist und sich insbesondere der Westen, die nicht asiatischen Teile dieser Welt,
sich ein wenig verhoben haben in der Bekämpfung, glaube ich, dieses Virus, mangels entsprechender Erfahrung mit Pandemien.
Man muss ja nur nach China gucken, da ist ja sozusagen Ruhe im Karton, noch zumindest derzeit.
Jetzt ist ja Impfstofftechnologie ganz neu in den Fokus geraten und die neue Aufmerksamkeit dürften Sie ja in gewisser Hinsicht auch genießen,
auch wenn die Situation jetzt nicht besonders angenehm ist.
Vielleicht erst mal so ganz allgemein, was ist Ihnen so durch den Kopf gegangen, als dieses Virus nach Europa geschwappt ist?
Haben Sie gleich geahnt, das wird nicht gut enden oder was war Ihre Erwartung am Anfang?
Ja gut, am Anfang waren die Meldungen aus China ja eher wie immer, man wusste es nicht so recht.
Und ich gebe Trump nicht so oft recht, aber in dem Fall schon, die WHO hätte da mal gerne bei China von Anfang an ein bisschen mehr bohren dürfen,
was geht da eigentlich ab bei euch, das hätte sicher nichts geschadet.
Hätte nicht viel geändert, man hätte trotzdem nicht viel ändern können, also der Virus wäre trotzdem weitergegangen, aber dann hätte man mehr Zeit gewonnen,
dass man einfach reagieren kann.
Ich sage mal, der Wendepunkt, also ganz am Anfang im Januar war ja noch nicht klar, ist das jetzt ein Virus wie der ursprüngliche SARS-Virus, der in der Lunge sitzt,
der die Leute zwar umbringt, aber im Prinzip relativ wenig infektiös ist oder haben wir da was anderes.
Und als dieser Webasto-Fall war, ich weiß nicht, ob Sie sich erinnern, das war der erste Infektionsfall in München,
In München.
wo ein Seminar war und es haben sich 14 Mitarbeiter angesteckt oder ich glaube, es waren nicht 14 Mitarbeiter, sondern das waren dann auch noch die Angehörigen,
aber das waren auf jeden Fall mehr oder weniger alle die im Raum waren.
So ein Supercluster auf jeden Fall.
Da bin ich schwer erschrocken, also das war für mich schon sehr sehr früh der Wendepunkt, wo ich gesagt habe, hoppla das ist nicht gut,
weil das bedeutet, dass die Infektiosität von dem Virus sehr hoch sein muss, weil im Regelfall sind Sie bei Business-Seminaren, dort küssen Sie sich nicht den ganzen Tag ab.
Schon gar nicht, wenn da eine Asiatin da ist, die ja im Regelfall sowieso eher distanzierter sind.
Also das heißt, wenn man sich da einfach durch das im Seminar-sein infizieren kann, war für mich damals schon klar, die Infektiosität von dem Erreger ist sicher ganz anders
wie von diesem damaligen SARS-Erreger, der sehr viel schwerer übergesprungen ist.
Und da war für mich klar, das kommt.
Also das wird man nicht verhindern können.
Und ich habe, das muss man halt wieder sagen, ich habe damals schon propagiert, da sollten wir von den Asiaten lernen und wir sollten mit den Masken gleich anfangen.
Leider hat damals das RKI gesagt, Masken schaden eher und das verstehe ich bis heute nicht, weil das macht natürlich jetzt, das fällt einem dann natürlich danach auf die Füße,
wenn man jetzt natürlich die Masken, Gott sei Dank, jetzt propagiert, hätte man früher machen können.
Ja, hätte hätte.
Also das ist so ein Punkt.
Also sprich, mir war das relativ früh klar, dass das nicht gut geht.
Meine Kinder, um ein Beispiel zu nennen, was das so im privaten Bereich eher bedeutet hat,
meine Kinder sind mit dem Skiclub SC Bütthard, die Bütthard hat 500 Einwohner, der Skiclub hat 1000 Mitglieder, die sind mit dem Skiclub zum Skifahren nach Südtirol
und das war in den Karnevalsferien, das müsste so 10. Februar +/- gewesen sein, ich weiß es nicht mehr ganz genau.
Februar.
Also so Mitte Februar, da war es ja noch relativ low das Thema hier oder man hat so ein bisschen gelächelt.
Das ist so die Zeit gewesen, wo über WhatsApp die ganzen …
Wo es in Italien auf einmal war.
Ja, in Italien ging es los, aber hier gingen noch über WhatsApp die ganzen Witze rüber.
Und ich habe gesagt, oja, darf das mal, das finde ich jetzt, ja da hingehen und ich habe dann bevor die hingefahren sind mit dem Leiter des Skiclubs telefoniert
und habe gesagt, also ich finde das problematisch, in Südtirol sind zwar erst zwei Fälle gemeldet offiziell, aber das kann nicht sein.
Also ich habe ein Jahr in Italien gelebt, die haben zwar drei-vier Städte abgesperrt, da hat es hundert Prozent mehr Fälle.
Und dann habe ich mich mit dem abgesprochen und gesagt, okay wir bleiben in Kontakt, ich habe jeden Tag mit dem telefoniert.
Also meine Kinder sind dann hin, aber ich wollte nur wissen, ob da jetzt der Mensch, der den Skiclub führt und der dort auch da ist,
ob der im Prinzip verantwortungsvoll ist und muss ich absolut sagen, ist er.
Und dann habe ich verfolgt, kommen Leute zurück von Südtirol mit Infektionen?
Und so war es, an Tag 3 nach dem Start von diesem Skiausflug war in Heidelberg einer, der sich in Südtirol infiziert hat.
Südtirol ist groß, ich habe dann beim Gesundheitsamt angerufen und gefragt, wo hat der sich infiziert?
Dann haben die gesagt, Datenschutz, dürfen sie nicht sagen.
Da habe ich gesagt, ich habe nicht gefragt, wo dieser Mensch jetzt wohnt, ich habe gefragt, wo hat der sich infiziert?
Und dann hat die tatsächlich Rücksprache gehalten und die haben dann 20 Minuten später tatsächlich rausgemailt, in welcher Ortschaft in Südtirol der sich infiziert hat.
Ich habe dann sofort mit dem Franz von dem Skiclub telefoniert, der hat gesagt, das ist 50 Kilometer von hier weg.
Da habe ich gesagt, oh, dann heißt das, dass das in der Gegend wahrscheinlich zirkuliert.
Dann habe ich gesagt, also meine Kinder sollen dann an dem Abend, wobei die 20 und 17 sind, also 20 ist natürlich volljährig, trotz allem nicht mehr Aprés Ski.
Und ich habe das mit dem besprochen, da hat er gesagt, das versteht er, er wird das ansprechen von dem Skiclub …
Er hat das bei allen angesprochen, von dem Skiclub war dann auch keiner mehr ab dem Tag im Aprés Ski.
Danach ging es dann mit Tirol weiter, die wollten einen Ausflug nach Tirol machen, der hat mich angerufen, das war zwei Wochen später,
das war also noch vor Ischgl und da hat er gesagt, die Risikoanalyse jetzt sehe ich ganz anders, ich habe jetzt schon das Problem,
dass wir beim Hinfahren im Bus schon einen drin sitzen haben kann.
Und dann hat der den Skiausflug sogar abgesagt mit zwei Bussen, 70 Leute, bevor das aufkam.
Da gehört schon einiges dazu, das durchzusetzen in der Zeit.
Da gehört einiges dazu und die haben 1000 Mitglieder.
Die hatten Ausflüge nach Südtirol und nach Tirol auch geplant, gemacht teilweise, und von den 1000 Mitgliedern hat sich kein einziger infiziert in den ganzen Skiurlauben.
Also es ging, das ist das, was mich so ein bisschen frustriert, man hätte viel früher reagieren können.
Und die Infektionsbildung, die ich kenne, bei den meisten war klar, das ist nicht gut.
Man hat nur natürlich Angst gehabt Grenzen zuzumachen und so weiter.
Es ist so, natürlich kann man nicht verhindern, dass der Virus kommt, das ist vollkommen illusorisch,
aber es ist ein Unterschied, ob ich mit 1000 verteilten Infektionsfällen anfange oder mit einzelnen Events, wo ich eine besondere Chance habe, die dann aufzuspüren und zu begrenzen.
Das ist die Problematik gewesen.
Also tatsächlich ist es so, dass sowohl die Hygieniker als auch die Infektionsbiologen da schon sehr früh die Alarmglocken geläutet haben
und ich meine, man hätte das jetzt natürlich trotzdem nicht, also die Politik hat, glaube ich, in Deutschland relativ gut reagiert, das muss man auch sagen
und natürlich hätte man nicht es geschafft, den Virus aus Deutschland rauszuhalten, also das möchte ich auch nicht sagen, wäre chancenlos gewesen.
Aber zumindest ein paar Tage oder Wochen gewinnen, hätte man schon hingekriegt, das hätte man wissen können.
Ja nachher ist man ja immer schlauer und ich denke, die ganze Gesellschaft durchlebt hier aber auch einen neuen Lernprozess.
Also ich meine, ein zweites, wenn man sich jetzt mal eine Zukunft vorstellt, was weiß ich, in zehn Jahren,
wir haben sozusagen dieses Problem auf die ein oder andere Art und Weise hinter uns gebracht
und es würde jetzt wieder irgendeine Zoonose im Raum stehen, dass hier ein Virus überspringt,
da wäre natürlich dann die Reaktionsbereitschaft wahrscheinlich eine ganz andere, je nachdem wie das jetzt alles noch ausgeht.
Man muss aber trotz allem festhalten, man kann natürlich an den Einzelpunkten kritisieren, aber insgesamt gesehen hat Deutschland wirklich gut reagiert,
das muss man auch dazu sagen, also man hätte vielleicht ein bisschen was besser machen können oder so, aber ich rede von bisschen was besser.
Wenn man da in die USA oder nach Brasilien guckt, das ist einfach nur verheerend, das ist ein komplettes Politikversagen
und die Menschen haben wirklich die Verantwortung, dass dort 200.000 Menschen gestorben sind, dass muss man einfach sagen
und diese Verantwortung muss sich die Regierung dort anziehen.
Und das ist in Deutschland sicher nicht so, dass da irgendwie leichtfertig oder so entschieden worden ist, das muss man auch sagen.
Ja, auf europäischer Ebene ist das sicherlich dann im Detail nochmal anders zu bewerten, da entwickeln sich ja derzeit die Zahlen auch nicht gerade besonders beruhigend.
Und ja gut, mit der nun viel diskutierten zweiten Welle, die so ein bisschen vor der Tür steht, haben wir natürlich genau die Situation,
dass wir schon eine ganz andere Verbreitung vor der Tür haben.
Etwas schwierig abzuschätzen, wie das ausgeht, da wollen wir mal jetzt auch gar nicht groß irgendwas vorhersagen,
was zum Zeitpunkt der Veröffentlichung dieses Podcasts ohnehin schon wieder ganz anders zu bewerten ist.
Aber jetzt wird es natürlich spannend, was die Impfstoffentwicklung betrifft.
Und jetzt kriegt dieses Feld ja auf einmal so einen ganz neuen Drive.
Weil gerade die Aspekte, die wir vorhin besprochen haben, so Finanzierung ist schwierig und man stürzt sich nur auf irgendwas,
was irgendwie auch noch in zehn Jahren vielleicht potenziell erfolgreich sein kann.
Jetzt sind ja die ganzen politischen Rahmenbedingungen auf einmal andere.
Also Geld spielt keine Rolle, man sieht, alles andere wäre viel viel teurer, was die Auswirkungen auf die Wirtschaft betrifft
und natürlich auch generell die Einschränkungen auf die Leute.
Und ja, man sieht eine große Bereitschaft auch, alle Prozesswege, die derzeit solche Sachen verzögern oder zumindest schwierig zu machen
soweit zu vereinfachen, zu parallelisieren, um eine entsprechende Entwicklung voranzutreiben.
Das hat dazu geführt, dass wir, glaube ich, ich weiß gar nicht, mit welchen Zahlen man jetzt hier auffahren muss,
also ich habe gehört von 14 verschiedenen Ansätzen, technischen Ansätzen, die sich auf noch sehr viel mehr Projekte und Projektgruppen erstrecken.
Weltweit in vielen Ländern werden Impfverfahren jetzt angestrebt.
Wie blicken Sie denn jetzt auf diese Entwicklung, mit der vielleicht ja auch zu rechnen war?
Also es ist schon faszinierend zu sehen, dass jetzt, sagen wir mal,
ein dicker Scheinwerfer auf die ganze Impfstoffentwicklung drauf ist
und auch selbst für mich so ein bisschen überraschend, dasss ein großer Teil dieser Entwicklungen wirklich neue Technologien sind,
die da durchgeführt werden.
Und also ich sehe das wirklich positiv, weil es geht wirklich drum, dass wir schnell einen Impfstoff brauchen,
es ist klar, dass jetzt natürlich die ganzen Prozesse der Zulassung das dann natürlich absolute Prio ist
und dass das keine normale Entwicklung ist, wo die Behörde dann, was weiß ich,
zwei Monate Zeit hat zum Revieren und was weiß ich was alles und da natürlich weniger Geld da ist.
Man wartet dann immer erst mal Phase 1 ab und dann kommt wieder Geld rein und macht Phase 2.
Jetzt macht man das natürlich so, dass man im Prinzip schon von vornherein das durchfinanziert hat mehr oder weniger
und wenn man halt Pech hat, ist das Geld halt weg, aber anders kann man das natürlich auf die Geschwindigkeit nicht machen.
Und es ist auch richtig so, weil es ist klar, dass ein Impfstoff bei so einer Epidemie,
wie Sie schon sagten, mit dem kann ich das Prinzip wieder abschalten.
Und deshalb muss man politisch gesehen da auch in die Vollen gehen,
weil man kann das nicht einfach weiter laufen lassen und kracht zusammen,
das ist gar keine Frage.
Es sind ja mehrere unterschiedliche Ansätze drin, also wie gesagt,
also dass man diese unterschiedlichen Ansätze jetzt auch betreibt und nicht sich auf einen konzentriert, halte ich für sehr sehr sinnvoll.
Weil wahrscheinlich ist es schon so, dass der Impfstoff, der dann nachher kommt, im Wesentlichen über Antikörper funktioniert,
dass ich einfach einen Antikörper habe, der an den Virus bindet, dann kann der Virus nicht mehr an seinen Rezeptor binden,
und dann war es das für den Virus, weil das ist das schöne an Viren im Gegensatz zu Bakterien,
wenn die Viren aus der Zelle nicht in der Zelle drin sind, dann machen die eben nichts, weil die können sich nicht ohne Zelle vermehren.
Das heißt, da habe ich es eigentlich einfach, ich muss einfach nur gucken, wenn er nicht reinkommt,
du kommst hier nicht rein, dann ist es für den Virus gelaufen.
Und deshalb ist es wichtig, ein normaler Virusimpfstoff muss es einfach schaffen,
dass so genügend Antikörper da sind, dass der nicht in die Zelle reinkommt.
Warum haben wir keinen Impfstoff gegen Hepatitis C und gegen HIV, wenn man sagt, wäre doch dann auch so?
Die gehen eben blöderweise gerade in die Immunzellen wieder rein.
Da sind wir wieder wie bei Tuberkulose und so weiter.
Das heißt, da funktionieren Antikörper nicht.
Also bei jedem Virus, wo Antikörper nicht vom Prinzip her nicht funktionieren können,
ist es viel schwieriger einen Impfstoff zu entwickeln.
Also so wie es aussieht, dürfte das bei Corona mit Antikörpern funktionieren.
Aber wenn ich das richtig sehe, ich meine, wir reden ja jetzt umgangssprachlich immer von dem Corona- Virus,
aber es ist ja sozusagen eigentlich nur ein Corona-Virus, weil es eine ganze Familie von Viren darstellt,
von denen es halt schon andere gegeben hat, wo halt auch die normalen Erkältungskrankheiten mit reinfallen.
Es gibt aber bisher noch eigentlich gar keinen einzigen Impfstoff gegen irgendeinen Corona-Virus,
sollte das Bedenken wecken, dass es hier technologisch eine Schranke gibt, die bisher noch keiner hat überspringen können
oder ist es sozusagen nur so, dass der Druck bisher noch nicht groß genug war, einen solchen zu entwickeln?
Naja, bei Corona ist es ja so, ich muss jetzt sagen, bei Jahreszahlen bin ich ein bisschen schwach,
ich glaube, das war 1800 irgendwas, da ist schon mal so ein Corona-Virus auf den Menschen frisch übergesprungen,
und der hat am Anfang auch relativ Harakiri gemacht, also das sah nicht gut aus, da haben relativ viele Leute sich infiziert
und sind auch gestorben, und damals gab es halt noch nicht diese Vernetzung und so weiter,
das heißt die Ausbreitungsgeschwindigkeit war anders, der hat sich aber beruhigt ist jetzt ein ganz normaler Erkältungsvirus geworden.
Das muss einem erst mal noch mal klar sein, was für einen Virus eigentlich Sinn macht, Leute umbringen ist für einen Virus eigentlich doof.
Also ich empfehle den Leuten, meinen Studenten empfehle ich immer, dieses Spiel zu spielen,
das nennt sich Plaque Inc., da können Sie, ich weiß nicht, ob Sie das kennen.
Ein Spiel um so eine Ausbreitung einer Seuche sozusagen.
Genau, und das ist lehrreich, weil es bringt Ihnen nichts, als Virus Leute schnell umzubringen.
Und der ursprüngliche SARS-Virus der saß in der Lunge drin, eigentlich nur in der Lunge
und wenn der erst mal in der Lunge ist, ist es ganz schlecht, dann ist einfach Lungenentzündung
und wenn Sie da ein bisschen angeschlagen sind oder so, überleben Sie das einfach nicht.
Aber zum Verbreiten ist Lunge doof, weil da müssen Sie erst mal rein und wieder raus.
Da hocken Sie also ganz unten im dunklen Eck und keiner findet Sie, das heißt die Infektiösität war gering.
Jetzt ist das Besondere an dem SARS-Cov-2 war ja, dass der im Prinzip die oberen Atemwege infizieren konnte von Anfang an
und dann aber auch in die Lunge runtergewandert ist, das ist also mehr oder weniger so ein Überbleibsel.
Also verbreitet sich gut, aber richtet viel Schaden an?
Kann aber auch Schaden anrichten, der geht nicht bei jedem in die Lunge runter.
Der macht auch noch viele andere Sachen, man hat viele Sachen auch nicht verstanden.
Aber für den Virus jetzt zum sich verbreiten, kann der eigentlich auf das Lungenzeug verzichten.
Also das heißt, wenn ich ein Mutante habe, die noch besser die oberen Atemwege infizieren kann
und die Lunge nicht mehr, der wird sich mehr verbreiten wie dieser noch mit Lungen-Virus.
Weil der Host halt nicht stirbt und man kann halt länger…
Der stirbt nicht und der ist dann noch infektiöser, kann noch mehr Leute anstecken.
Der ist aber natürlich dann im Endeffekt, wenn der Lunge gar nicht mehr kann, ist es wieder ein harmloser Erkältungsvirus.
Das heißt, auch dieser Virus wird sich wahrscheinlich irgendwann mal, wenn man den einfach lässt, zu einem Erkältungsvirus entwickeln irgendwann.
Mit Betonung auf irgendwann.
Nachdem er alle Menschen gekillt hat, die schlecht drauf reagieren.
Alle wird er nicht gekillt haben, aber das heißt, wenn man jetzt sagt, man lässt es drauf ankommen,
ist das nicht mutig, sondern das ist fahrlässig.
So und jetzt diese Corona-Viren, die wir jetzt zirkulieren haben, das sind Erkältungsviren.
Früher vielleicht waren die auch mal schlimmer, jetzt aber nicht mehr, das heißt, die machen eine Erkältung.
Und wir alle haben zwei-drei Erkältungen im Jahr.
Das ist zwar doof, da läuft die Nase, aber kein Mensch würde auch die Idee kommen, da sind wir wieder bei dieser Abwägung,
sich gegen eine Erkältung impfen zu lassen, weil das ist eine Erkältung, meine Herren, also da stirbt keiner dran, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Und deshalb gibt es natürlich auch keine Impfstoffe gegen Corona, weil warum sollte man?
Natürlich kann man sich immer wieder anstecken, das ist so ein bisschen, dass man sagt, wie lange schützt das eigentlich?
Also ehrlich gesagt, ich bin jetzt kein absoluter Corona-Experte, dass ich Ihnen sagen kann,
wenn ich eine Erkältung hatte mit einem bestimmten Corona-Virus, wie lange bin ich geschützt gegen genau den gleichen Typ,
weil es gibt natürlich mehrere Erkältungsviren, das heißt, die nächste Erkältung ist möglicherweise nicht genau der Virus,
sondern ein anderer, das glaube ich auch, aber ich weiß es einfach nicht, wie lange die Immunität hält.
Aber es gibt eine?
Eine gewisse Immunität gibt es schon.
Also wenn Sie die Erkältung erstmal weg haben, sind Sie die nächste Woche nicht normalerweise sofort wieder erkältet, das ist die Immunität.
Also das heißt, dass man eine Immunität entwickeln kann gegen Corona-Virus, das wäre schon sehr erstaunlich,
wenn dem nicht so der Fall wäre.
Also warum gibt es noch keine Impfstoffe gegen Corona, das ist der Grund, warum schon.
War einfach bisher nicht dramatisch genug.
Ja.
Und bei dem SARS-1, der war zu schnell wieder weg.
Der war zu schnell wieder weg, genau, das ist so der Punkt.
Das heißt jetzt nicht, dass es keine Hürden gibt, das muss man auch sagen.
Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass man sagt, pff Virus, ich habe gesagt, man macht dann einen Antikörper, blockt das und fertig.
Kann sein, dass das auf diese ganz einfache Art und Weise reicht, es kann aber auch sein, dass es nicht ganz so reicht,
weil der Hauptweg ist ja die Lunge, das heißt, idealerweise brauche ich da Antikörper, die nicht in der Blutzirkulation sind,
sondern die müssen ja in der Schleimhaut drin sein dann diese Antikörper.
Und diese Antikörper muss ich induzieren und das ist wieder was, das ist nicht ganz so einfach.
Also nicht ganz so einfach, sage ich mal, also das heißt nicht, dass es unmöglich ist, aber ich brauche diese Antikörper.
Und nicht nur Antikörper, die im Blut rumschwimmen.
Weil wenn der erst mal im Blut ist, ist schon zu spät, ich muss die in der Lunge abfangen.
Und ich brauche genug von diesen Antikörpern, das ist auch ein Punkt.
Das heißt, wenn ich da einen Antikörper habe und es kommt ein Virus, dann macht der Antikörper gar nichts,
weil der Virus dann natürlich noch von seinen, ich weiß nicht, wieviele Surface-Proteine der drauf hat, sagen wir mal tausend,
keine Ahnung, das könnte man natürlich theoretisch bestimmen, aber wenn ich jetzt tausend habe und eins von den tausend ist blockiert,
dann habe ich immer noch 999…
Also nicht tausend unterschiedliche, sondern tausend Angriffsstellen?
Tausend Angriffsstellen genau.
Das sind diese Spike-Proteine
Diese Spike-Proteine genau.
Quasi die Anknüpfungsstelle, mit denen er an die Zellen andockt und sein Geschäft verrichtet?
Genau, und damit der Impfstoff effizient ist, muss ich natürlich die alle blockieren.
Es reicht nicht, wenn ich die Hälfte blockiere oder zehn, wenn ich die Hälfte blockiere, ist der Impfstoff komplett unwirksam.
Ich muss wirklich alle blockieren, und deshalb muss der eigentlich, das ist das wichtige, der muss also eine Effizienz haben,
dass ich genug Antikörper habe auch.
Und das ist der Punkt, man kann natürlich jetzt, deshalb ist es eine Entwicklung, man weiß jetzt natürlich nicht bei so einem Virus,
den man nicht kennt, wieviele Antikörper brauche ich denn?
Also man kann jetzt nicht einfach sagen, jetzt impfe ich einfach mal 20 Gesunde, messe wieviele Antikörper haben die entwickelt
und wenn die Antikörper haben, die über, was weiß ich, 2 mg/ml Blut liegen, dann sind die geschützt, weiß ich nicht,
also das heißt, das muss ich erst mal rausfinden.
Das heißt, ich bin vollkommen davon überzeugt, dass bei dem Virus eine Antikörperantwort die primäre Antwort ist, die ich brauche,
einfach vom Grundprinzip her und weil jetzt nichts darauf hindeutet, dass der Virus primär Immunzellen infiziert,
aber wieviel, das weiß man nicht.
Und vor allem kann man diese Antikörper, die in der Schleimhaut sind, die findet man natürlich in der Blutzirkulation nicht.
Das heißt, die können Sie schlecht messen, das heißt, sind da auch genug da von diesen mukosalen Antikörpern
Das heißt, das sind so die Sachen, wo man erst mal lernen muss, wo man erst mal Erfahrungen sammeln muss.
Also dass man, wenn ich in der Zirkulation beispielsweise dann 5 mg/ml Antikörper habe, heißt das,
dass ich auch in der Lunge von den anderen genug habe und dann ist man geschützt.
Das sieht man aber erst, wenn man die klinischen Studien gemacht hat, das sieht man vorher nicht.
Man kann ja derzeit sich auch schon auf Antikörper testen lassen, aber dann wird ja in der Regel Blut entnommen,
das heißt, die Antikörper, die man jetzt im Blut findet, die sagen alle erst mal gar nichts aus oder?
Nein, die sagen im Prinzip erst mal aus, dass Sie, wenn Sie Antikörper haben, dass Sie mal infiziert waren.
Es gab eine Infektion.
Und wenn Sie gesund sind, dann heißt das eigentlich auch, dass Ihr Immunsystem den Virus in Schach gehalten hat.
Okay, aber wenn das sozusagen als Reaktion auf einen Impfstoff, den man gegeben hat, dann sagt es vielleicht nicht unbedingt was aus.
Es ist natürlich schon der primäre Parameter, was ich sage, natürlich messen sie die Antikörper.
Was ich nur sagen möchte ist, dass sie das erst mal normieren müssen.
Sie müssen erst mal wissen, wieviele Antikörper brauche ich denn?
Sie werden Antikörper brauchen, aber Sie wissen eben noch nicht wieviele.
Aber kann man sie auch so ohne weiteres messen im Rachen?
Also lassen sie sich da genauso auf dieselbe Art und Weise nachweisen, wie man sie im Blut nachweist?
Deutlich weniger einfach.
Messen können Sie viel, auch im Rachen, Sie können Abstriche machen, Sie können die dann ausschütteln
Aber das ist deutlich weniger einfach, die Methode ist deutlich weniger quantitativ.
Im Blut ist es sehr sehr einfach, wirklich quantitativ genau Antikörper zu bestimmen und das wird man auch immer machen.
Und man korreliert das dann, also man nimmt dann diese Blutantikörper und korreliert das,
sagt, aufgrund der Erfahrung entspricht das so und so viel IGA-Antikörper, das sind die, die in der Mucosa drin sind.
Natürlich sind die im Blut nicht vollkommen nutzlos, das ist schon klar.
Mucosa im Speichel sozusagen.
Genau in der Schleimhaut drin, in der Mucosa.
Das heißt, um die geht es IGA, das ist sozusagen das was wir wollen?
Die wollen wir vor allem, wenn Sie eine Infektion haben in der Lunge.
Jetzt haben Sie ja schon erwähnt, ist alles ganz spannend, weil jetzt kommen ja viele neue Technologien zustande.
Da fragt man sich natürlich erst mal, was ist denn mit denen, die sich schon bewährt haben?
Taugen die nichts oder wollen jetzt alle ihr neuestes Spielzeug ausprobieren, warum geschieht da jetzt auf einmal so viel auf so vielen Bereichen?
Weil man alles mögliche ausprobieren will oder weil man das erste Mal hofft, mit irgendwas Erfolg zu haben?
Oder sind die neuen Technologien in gewisser Hinsicht vielversprechender oder hat es mehr was damit zu tun,
wieviele Impftsoffdosierungen man ausgeben möchte?
Was sind da so die treibenden Faktoren?
Naja, also ich sage mal so, Sie sagten ja selber, es gibt noch keinen Corona-Impfstoff,
das heißt, das Risiko ist immer da, dass natürlich trotzdem, was ich jetzt sagte, es ist sehr wahrscheinlich,
aber zwischen sehr wahrscheinlich und sicher ist ein großer Unterschied.
Und wenn Sie jetzt eine Epidemie haben, wo Sie die ganze Welt schützen müssen, dann würde ich auf nur sehr wahrscheinlich nicht gerne setzen wollen.
Das heißt, ein klassischer Impfstoff, der, sagen wir mal, straight forward Impfstoff, wo wirkt gegen viele virale Erkrankungen,
ist einfach Hepatitis B zum Beispiel, das ist einfach, ich nehme das Surface-Proteine von dem Virus,
gentechnisch erzeuge ich das zum Beispiel in Hefezellen, also nur dieses Oberflächenprotein,
mache noch ein Adjuvans dazu, das ist ein Wirkverstärker, den ich brauche, dass das überhaupt funktioniert,
wir haben vorher drüber geredet bei den Bakterien, spritzt das und ich werde mit dem Ding Antikörper kriegen,
auf jeden Fall EGG genug, das sind die, die im Blut zirkulieren, IGA je nachdem wie ich es mache.
Das wird funktionieren, also ich werde mit so einem Impfstoff Antikörper kriegen.
Ich weiß allerdings nicht wie gesagt, reicht es in der Lunge, brauche ich das vielleicht ein bisschen besser?
Das heißt, das wird ja auch gemacht.
Natürlich werden so Impfstoffe jetzt auch entwickelt, es ist ja nicht so, dass nur die modernen entwickelt werden,
sondern natürlich werden die klassischen Impfschienen auch gefahren.
Problem ist, wie gesagt, ich weiß es nicht, reicht mir das, kriege ich da genug raus?
Wahrscheinlich schon.
Also ich könnte mir jetzt aus dem Bauchgefühl raus schon vorstellen, dass das geht.
Das zweite Problem ist, dass die Entwicklungsgeschwindigkeit bei dem ein bisschen länger ist,
weil ich muss den erst mal in eine Hefezelle reinbringen beispielsweise, ich muss den erst mal exprimieren,
ich muss den dann aufreinigen und so weiter und das dauert Zeit.
Das heißt, wenn ich eine große Produktion von dem mache, brauche ich eine längere Zeit
wie von diesen mMRNA-Impfstoffen, die wahrscheinlich die ersten sind, die zulassungsreif sind.
Also wenn die Phase 3 Studien, die jetzt ja laufen, funktionieren und die ersten, die die Phase 3 Ergebnisse haben werden,
sind diese mMRNA-Impfstoffe.
Warum?
Weil die schnell zu entwickeln sind und, das muss man auch sagen, das ist nicht nur in den Schoß gefallen,
sondern die Leute von Biontech beispielsweise, der Uğur Şahin, die haben sofort reagiert.
Der Uğur Şahin hat gesehen, da kommt Corona, der hat sofort sich voll darauf gestürzt.
Es war auch ein Risiko, es hätte auch sein können, dass dann nachher das Geld dann, dass alle sagen, wir machen das anders,
aber der hat das Risiko auf sich genommen und gesagt, wir machen das sofort, das ist wichtig.
Die kommen auch eher aus der Tumorecke, ich kenne die noch von den ganzen Kongressen damals von der Tumorimmunologie.
Und ich finde das gut, also man muss dann auch sofort reagieren, sofort reingehen.
Ob dieser Impfstoff dann wirkt oder nicht, kann man natürlich erst nach der Phase 3 sagen, ich hoffe es sehr, das ist ja klar.
Aber trotzdem muss man die Ergebnisse abwarten.
Dann schauen wir uns doch mal kurz diese Technik an.
Also mMRNA-Messenger, RNA oder Boten-RNA, also auf welche Art und Weise geht man jetzt hier vor und warum ist das so schnell?
Also was macht sozusagen jetzt diese Technik aus, dass sie jetzt hier mit in den Ring geworfen wird?
Okay, also schnell ist sie deshalb, weil Sie müssen nicht den Umweg gehen über, irgendwas in eine Zelle reinklonieren
und das dann exprimieren und herstellen, aufreinigen und so weiter, das können Sie „relativ schnell chemisch“ eher machen.
Also mit, ich weiß nicht, ehrlich gesagt weiß ich gar nicht, wie die das synthetisieren, aber ich denke,
das ist chemisch, so Festphasensynthese oder irgendwas, also das geht einfacher.
Der Impfstoff selber ist für mich ehrlich gesagt überraschend, dass das überhaupt geht mit RNA.
Also als ich das das erste Mal gelesen habe, das ist ein paar Jahre her, dass die mit dem RNA-Ansatz fahren, war das für mich überraschend.
Ich komme ja aus, ich habe es ja angedeutet, in Berlin und auch schon in Sienna habe ich mit DNA-Impfstoffen gearbeitet.
Das heißt, was wir da genommen haben ist nackte DNA.
Jetzt für die Zuhörer, wo Biologie vielleicht schon bisschen weiter zurücklegt, vielleicht sollten wir dann immer kurz aufgreifen, was was ist.
Also DNA ist die Erbinformation, die wir in unseren Zellen drin haben, das ist das große Buch.
Das wird dann in jede Zelle immer verteilt, da steht alles drin.
Die DNA wird, wenn ich ein Protein herstellen würde, dann würde diese DNA in RNA, in Messenger-RNA übersetzt
und diese Messenger-RNA wird dann später in ein Protein übersetzt.
Das heißt, die RNA ist der Schritt danach, die DNA kommt vorher.
Und wir haben damals relativ viel DNA-Immunisierung gemacht, ich war auch im Labor,
ich habe Tiere gespritzt mit dem, der diese DNA-Immunisierung erfunden hat, Jeff Ulmer, der auch bei Novartis ist
Und das hießt, da spritzt man DNA direkt, das muss in den Zellkern reingehen, wird dann abgelesen,
in RNA übersetzt, in ein Protein gemacht und geht dann raus.
Der Vorteil ist, dass diese DNA, wir haben über Wirkverstärker geredet, eine bakterielle DNA ist was,
was das Immunsystem selber schon anregt.
Das heißt, ich habe in dieser DNA die Wirkverstärkung schon eingebaut.
So das hat man bei RNA eher nicht und das zweite Problem ist, DNA ist relativ stabil, RNA ist relativ instabil.
Das heißt, damals als wir das gemacht haben, hätten wir nicht gedacht, dass das mit RNA überhaupt funktionieren kann,
einfach weil RNA viel schneller abgebaut wird, geht aber.
Also das haben die Leute aus Tübingen, aus Mainz und so weiter gezeigt, geht.
Und das ist natürlich ein riesiger Vorteil.
Weil die DNA, das hört sich jetzt an, das ist eigentlich kein Unterschied, würde man sagen, ob wir jetzt DNA nehmen oder RNA,
es macht aber von der Sicherheit einen riesigen Unterschied.
Weil die DNA, wenn ich jetzt DNA in eine Zelle reinspritze, dann besteht die Gefahr, dass diese DNA in das Chromosom sich einbaut.
Und das ist nicht gut, weil wenn sich die DNA einbaut, könnte die zum Beispiel ein Gen kaputt machen,
das eigentlich dafür sorgt, dass die Zelle keinen Krebs kriegt, das nennt sich Tumorsupressor.
Also die können den Tumorsupressor kaputt machen, wenn die integriert werden.
Oder es könnte neben einem Gen reingehen und es schaltet dann das Gen daneben an, das dann ein Onkogen ist
und die Zelle in den Tumor greifen, das kann bei DNA passieren.
Also das Risiko ist bei einem DNA-Vakzin da.
Das Risiko gibt es gar nicht bei RNA, weil die RNA im Regelfall nicht in DNA zurückverwandelt werden.
Das können Viren wie HIV, die haben eine reverse Transkriptase, aber unsere Zellen machen so was nicht.
Also es taugt nur als Bauvorschrift für die Proteine?
Nur als Bauvorschrift für das Virenhüllprotein, die Gefahr besteht nicht, dass das nachher wieder im Zellkern drin ist.
Das heißt, die RNA-Impfstoffe sind natürlich wesentlich sicherer.
Also wenn ich jetzt in der Zeitung lesen würde, dass alle Impfstoffe, obwohl ich mit diesen Impfstoffen Jahre gearbeitet habe,
die jetzt in der Entwicklung sind, DNA-Impfstoffe wären, hätte ich ein bisschen Bauchschmerzen.
Weil wenn jetzt plötzlich sieben Jahre Menschen mit so einem Impfstoff gespritzt werden, da sind die Risiken natürlich schon real.
Beim RNA-Impfstoff sind diese Risiken, also die mechanistisch von der RNA kommen, deutlich geringer.
Es gibt natürlich immer Impfstoffnebenwirkungen, natürlich muss man immer auch in den großen Studien sich sorgfältig anschauen,
ob man irgendwelche überraschenden Effekte hat, die man vorher nicht auf dem Radar hatte,
aber diese problematischen Effekte, Integration, Tumorentwicklung und so weiter werde ich mit einem RNA-Impfstoff nicht haben.
Aber gibt es denn überhaupt schon irgendeinen Impfstoff für irgendetwas, was auf diesem RNA-Verfahren basiert oder ist das noch "unproven"? Gibt's keinen, oder?
Nein, soweit ich weiß, nicht.
Gibt es keinen.
Und deshalb ist es natürlich, ich glaube, für die ganzen Leute, die jetzt aus dem Impfstoffbereich kommen, die schauen sich das jetzt mit großen Augen an.
In der Situation würde ich sehr wünschen, dass das funktioniert, weil das jetzt scheinbar die Biontech/Pfizer das werden die ersten sein,
wenn der nicht funktioniert, wäre das doof.
Das heißt nicht, dass dann kein anderer Impfstoff kommen kann, das glaube ich nicht, aber das heißt, dass es dauern wird.
Und je früher desto besser.
Okay, also nur um das mal zu verstehen, im Prinzip ist das Zufall.
Also wir sind sozusagen technologisch gerade so weit, dass diese mMRNA-basierte Methode zur Anwendung gebracht werden kann überhaupt,
dass man überhaupt erst mal nachgewiesen hat, aha okay, das führt auch dazu, dass Antikörper erzeugt werden
und mehr oder weniger zufällig fällt das jetzt eben in diese Krise rein, so dass man sagt, okay alles klar,
jetzt sind wir hier schon einen Schritt weiter gekommen, mal gucken, ob wir das jetzt hier auch konkret zur Anwendung bringen können
und es gibt da, sagen wir mal, Hoffnung?
Also Zufall, ich würde es vielleicht nicht ganz so negativ formulieren, ich würde es so als Glück formulieren.
Ja, oder so, ja gut, das läuft ja auf das Gleiche raus.
Weil das ist ja jetzt nicht so …
Wir wissen ja noch nicht, ob wir Glück haben werden damit, von daher ist das erst mal nur Zufall und vielleicht Glück.
Glück, dass man auf diese Entwicklung aufspringen kann, das nenne ich Glück.
Also ob der funktioniert, das habe ich ja schon gesagt, das kann man jetzt noch nicht abschätzen.
Diese RNA-Impfstoffe sind natürlich auch eher im Tumorbereich entwickelt worden,
weil wie ich vorher sagte, um Krebs zu bekämpfen, nützen Ihnen nur Antikörper nichts
und mit einem RNA-Impfstoff können Sie eben, im Gegensatz zu dem Protein-Impfstoff, können Sie mit dem RNA-Impfstoff eben auch eine zelluläre Antwort induzieren.
Also diese Killerzellen.
Das heißt, diese Killerzellen können Sie mit dem induzieren.
Das können Sie mit einem Protein-Impfstoff nicht.
Das heißt, diese Antikörper macht der, aber eben auch die anderen Sachen.
Dass der Antikörper machen kann, das war vorher auch schon bekannt.
Also das ist jetzt nicht so, dass man jetzt vollkommen überrascht ist, ein RNA-Impfstoff kann auch Antikörper, natürlich kann er das auch.
Die Frage ist immer, wie viel, ja also das ist wieder eine Effizienzfrage.
Okay, aber wissen wir jetzt, heißt, vor zehn Jahren wussten wir es noch nicht?
Vor zehn Jahren gab es RNA-Impfstoffe noch gar nicht.
Okay, also das heißt, das ist also wirklich eine Entwicklung der letzten Jahre?
Ja, der letzten Jahre.
Trotzdem sind die traditionellen Methoden auch noch eine Option?
Ja selbstverständlich, die werden ja auch gemacht und es wäre auch Wahnsinn zu sagen, ich mache jetzt nur auf RNA-Impfstoff,
sondern die werden auch gemacht.
Wie gesagt, es kann sein, wenn jetzt Antikörper ein Baustein sind, wenn der Virus doch mehr so Richtung Hepatitis C oder HIV geht,
wo ich dann auch eine zelluläre Antwort brauche, da wird man mit den Protein-Impfstoffen dann überhaupt nicht hinkommen,
das muss man sagen, also die gehen da nicht.
Also dann wäre es fatal, wenn man nicht Impfstoffe in der Pipeline hat, die das eben auch können, diese zelluläre Antwort zu induzieren.
Und das tun diese RNA-Impfstoffe sicherlich, wenn auch der Fokus jetzt natürlich bei den Antikörpern ist,
das tun auch die Rekombinanten-Impfstoffe, also diese Impfstoffe, die auf lebenden Viren basieren,
die aber harmlos sind, auf die man dann dieses Corona-Antigen dazu packt.
Die können sicherlich eben auch diese zelluläre Antwort induzieren.
Jetzt gibt es ja schon in Russland einen ersten Impfstoff angeblich, was steckt dahinter?
Also da muss ich sagen, Bauchschmerzen ist noch das wenigste was ich da sage.
Als ich das gelesen habe, dass die mit eigentlich einer Phase 1 Studie mit 30-40 Leuten sagen,
so bamm wir haben einen Impfstoff und wir gehen jetzt groß rein, das ist, ich finde das absolut unverantwortlich,
das muss man einfach knallhart so sagen.
Da kann man sagen, es kann gut gehen, aber es kann auch schiefgehen.
Und das ist, Gott sei Dank geht so was bei uns nicht, muss ich sagen, also das ist verheerend.
Dieser Impfstoff ist ein rekombinanter Impfstoff, also der Impfstoff selber ist jetzt nicht doof gemacht oder irgendwas,
also nach dem Motto, die Russen machen da irgendeinen Murks, dem ist nicht so, der ist schon, ich weiß jetzt nicht,
ob er auf MVA oder auf Adenovirus beruht, also der Virus …
Adenoviren sind es.
Sind Adenoviren, okay.
Also diese Adenoviren sind im Prinzip lebend, die sind harmlos und die sind modifiziert mit diesem Surface-Protein von dem SARS-CoV-2.
Der Ansatz ist schon sinnvoll, das ist gar keine Frage, aber dieses Prinzip gibt es im Prinzip auch noch nicht auf dem Markt.
Also dass man mit so einem rekombinanten Lebendimpfstoff reingeht.
Und diese Viren, was ich jetzt gesagt habe bei den RNA-Impfstoffen, dass schon sehr viel doof laufen muss,
dass der wirklich ganz problematische Nebenwirkungsprofile zeigt, bei so einem Impfstoff, der auf einem Lebendimpfstoff basiert,
ist natürlich jetzt deutlich wahrscheinlicher, dass da auch schwere Nebenwirkungen da sein können,
die man so nicht auf dem Schirm hat.
Das heißt, so einen Virus zu entwickeln gegen Corona ist gut, aber bei dem ist es um so wichtiger, bei den klinischen Studien wirklich sorgfältig zu schauen,
wie sehen meine Nebenwirkungsprofile aus?
Der Impfstoff von Astra Zeneca beispielsweise beruht auf dem gleichen Prinzip.
Und da war ja dieser große Aufschrei, als es dieses Event gab, wo man dann, was ganz normal ist, dann wird das gehalten,
das wird analysiert und dann wird entschieden, ist es …
Also es gab eine Komplikation bei einer Testperson und daraufhin ist erstmal die weitere Entwicklung angehalten worden.
Genau, die klinischen Studien wurden dann angehalten, es wurden keine Menschen mehr immunisiert und dann wird analysiert,
ob der Fall, wie wahrscheinlich das ist, dass das durch die Impfung geschehen ist oder nicht.
Man muss sich vorstellen, diese großen Phase 3 Studien, das sind ja zehntausende Menschen drin.
Und natürlich, wenn Sie jetzt 10.000 Menschen einfach so zwei-drei Monate beobachten würden,
wird natürlich mal irgendeiner einen Herzinfarkt kriegen oder irgendwas.
Und bei der Studie müssen Sie natürlich sicher sein, dass das nicht durch Ihren Impfstoff ausgelöst wird,
das heißt, Sie müssen dann, wenn so was kommt, schauen, ist das jetzt ein Herzinfarkt, weil der einfach einen Herzinfarkt hat
oder ist das eine Nebenwirkung von meinem Impfstoff?
Wir reden wie gesagt von einem Impfstoff, der nachher sieben Milliarden Menschen gegeben werden soll
und da will man sich verdammt noch mal sicher sein, dass der eben nicht plötzlich jedem tausendsten einen Herzinfarkt reindrückt.
Und das muss man dann einfach ausschließen können.
Und das ist was, was bei diesem russischen Impfstoff beispielsweise einfach unterlassen wurde und das ist grob fahrlässig.
Ja, an der Stelle wird dann sozusagen noch mal ein anderes gesellschaftspolitisches Problem deutlich,
dass es eben mittlerweile ja auch eine Frage der Politik ist, wie man hier vorgeht und dass so bestimmte Herrscher sich viel davon versprechen,
hier sozusagen zum Befreier der Menschheit sich hochspielen zu können.
Das sehen wir in den USA, das ist sicherlich auch ein Faktor in Russland, gibt es bestimmt auch noch ein paar andere Länder, die hier verdächtig sind.
In gewisser Hinsicht nachvollziehbar, dass man hier gerne groß wirken möchte, aber das gefährdet ja dann schon wieder das gesamte wissenschaftliche Gebäude.
Genau, das ist das Problem.
Das Problem ist halt, wenn in Russland das jetzt rauskommt, dass sie den zurückziehen müssen, weil doch irgendwelche Nebenwirkungen auftreten,
dann haben wir natürlich in Gesellschaften wie hier in Deutschland, dann fühlen sich natürlich diese Impfgegner bestätigt
und sagen, wir wussten es doch.
Wir schreien gleich wieder los.
Und das ist natürlich das Problem, natürlich kann es gut gehen, also das ist nicht …
also ich würde es den Russen ja wünschen, ich will jetzt nicht, dass das Ding schief läuft.
Aber es ist einfach unverantwortlich, weil das nicht nur für die Menschen, die den Impfstoff dann kriegen, unverantwortlich ist,
aber eben für das ganze Feld unverantwortlich ist.
Und in Russland mag das dann nicht viel ausmachen, wenn dann Putin sagt, lief halt schief, jetzt haben wir einen neuen,
mag sein, dass die Russen dann alle begeistert sind, in Deutschland wird das verheerend sein, wenn dieser Impfstoff zurückgezogen wird.
Und jetzt kann man einfach nicht, mit diesen Prinzipien von diesem Impfstoff sind einfach die Erfahrung noch nicht da.
Also wenn ich jetzt diesem klassischen Surface-Protein als Protein aufgereinigt, Adjuvans dazu, reinspritzen,
da gibt es schon Millionenen Anwendungen mit anderen Antigenen, die so gemacht wurden, die auf dem Markt sind,
da müsste schon sehr sehr viel blöd laufen, dass jetzt bei so einem Corona-Impfstoff dann plötzlich wahnsinnig neue Nebenwirkungen auftreten.
Also das wäre man jetzt aus dem Wissenschaftlichen schon sich kaum vorstellen können.
Bei diesen Rekombinanten weiß man es einfach nicht.
Und bei dem RNA-Impfstoff hat man dieses, würde ich sagen, muss auch schon, da ist relativ unwahrscheinlich,
dass das Sicherheitsprofil deutlich anders aussieht wie bei einem Protein-Impfstoff.
Man muss es testen, man muss das sauber machen, aber es wäre schon sehr überraschend.
Tja, aber wir werden sehen, wie das Rennen so ausgeht.
Was ja dann am Ende auch noch ein Faktor ist, selbst wenn es diesen Wirkstoff gibt, der tatsächlich wirkt,
hängt es ja dann auch sehr vom jeweiligen Typ ab, wieviele Menschen er dann auch innerhalb welcher Zeit auf welche Art und Weise
und vor allem mit welcher Priorität verabreicht werden kann.
Können wir da noch mal kurz klassifizieren, wie das jetzt ist?
Wenn ich es richtig gesehen habe, müssen wir ja im Prinzip drei große Bereiche unterscheiden bei diesen Impfstoffklassen.
Haben die alle mehr oder weniger dieselbe Reproduzierbarkeit oder gibt es hier klare Vorteile für einen dieser Stoffklassen?
Ich weiß jetzt gerade gar nicht genau, auf was Sie hinaus wollen.
Naja, also wenn ich jetzt den Impfstoff habe, wie schnell kann ich da zehn Millionen Dosen von produzieren?
Wie finde ich raus, wieviele ich überhaupt brauche?
Also ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es tatsächlich ist bei dem Biontech, also bei den mMRNA, wenn die chemisch gemacht werden,
wie gesagt, ich bin da zu wenig im Prozess drin, dass sie das von der Produktion her möglicherweise relativ einfach hochziehen können,
dass sie das relativ leicht expandieren können.
Ich glaube, Elon Musk hat ja sogar auch schon angeklingelt und gesagt, er macht auch noch was.
Und wenn er in Berlin es schafft, in einem Jahr eine Gigafactory hinzustellen, wenn er dann einen Impfstoff macht,
kann man beruhigt sein, dann geht das auch.
Also ich denke, das ist ein Vorteil.
Ich glaube auch, das ist vielleicht auch ein Vorteil, wenn man dann eben unterschiedliche Technologien hat,
die unterschiedliche Produktionsmethoden ausnutzen, weil ich glaube, nur mit einem Impfstoff,
selbst mit einem RNA-Impfstoff, einen einzelne RNA-Impfstoff wird man nicht schaffen, so schnell wie möglich in die Welt zu drücken.
Es ist gut, wenn andere kommen, die nicht die gleichen Produktionskapazitäten brauchen, sondern die anders produziert werden können,
weil dann geht natürlich die Produktion insgesamt schneller.
Deshalb würde ich mich jetzt gar nicht so weit aus dem Fenster lehnen zu sagen, der ist viel besser als der andere,
weil natürlich gibt es auch für, wenn ich jetzt wieder auf das Surface-Protein gehe von Hepatits B,
natürlich ist diese Impfstoffproduktion, die Kapazität für die Impfstoffproduktion von so was, ist jetzt relativ überschaubar.
Aber das Ding könnte ich im Prinzip in jedem Bioreaktor machen.
Das heißt, wenn ich das will, dann kann ich bei Roche Penzberg und so weiter,
wobei die bei ihren Zellen natürlich keine Lust haben, dann eine Hefe hochzuziehen,
aber im Prinzip könnte man die Anlagen theoretisch umrüsten und sagen, ich gehe jetzt in diese Richtung.
Also man kann dann Kapazitäten natürlich auch freischaufeln.
Aber das ist schon klar, es wird nicht so sein, dass man, wenn morgen die Zulassung ist, dass man zwei Woche später sieben Milliarden Impfdosen hat,
also das ist vollkommen unrealistisch.
Das heißt, es wird, egal welcher Impfstoff kommt, mehr oder weniger lange dauern, bis ich alle durchgeimpft habe.
Machen wir mal einen Deckel auf das Corona-Thema, haben wahrscheinlich auch alle wieder viel zu viel von gehört bisher
und schauen wir doch nochmal auf die Wissenschaft in der Ausbildung.
Jetzt haben Sie ja eine Professur angenommen an der Hochschule Rhein-Waal für Biotechnologie und Bioengineering heißt das, glaube ich, offiziell.
Was hat Sie denn dazu bewogen, diesen Schritt zu gehen und worum geht es denn dort?
Gerne, vielleicht noch mal einen Nachtrag, fällt mir gerade auf, zu vorher.
Also Corona haben wir den Deckel drauf gemacht, aber was wir nicht angesprochen haben,
was eigentlich auch nicht Biotechnologie ist, aber was natürlich gesellschaftlich langfristig das viel größeren Problem wie Corona ist,
wird das Klima sein und ich glaube, ich bin immer ein grundsätzlicher Optimist, was man aus so einem Thema mitnehmen kann.
Man hätte sich gar nicht vorstellen können, was die Menschen mitmachen vor Corona-Zeiten.
Und was sie dann bereit sind, selber auch dann einzusetzen.
Und beim Klima hieß es bisher immer, nö das können wir alles nicht, das können wir uns nicht zumuten.
Unzumutbar ja.
Und ich glaube, da muss man, weil beim Klima ist es so, gegen Klimawandel wird es leider keinen Impfstoff geben.
Und der Klimawandel macht jetzt auch keine Pause, sondern der wird kommen und da ist meine Hoffnung in dem Gebiet,
dass dieser Drive dann mitgenommen wird und in den Klimawandel rein mitgenommen wird und das ist ganz wichtig.
Und da sind wir vielleicht auch dann, sagen wir mal, der Übergang nach Rhein-Waal, weil das ist das, was ich jetzt relativ viel mache.
Erneuerbare Energien, Systainability und so weiter, weil das ist natürlich das Thema Weltretten.
Das eine ist ein Virus, den kriegen wir hoffentlich nach einem Jahr los, entweder er ist in fünf Jahren ein Erkältungsvirus,
dann sind ein paar Millionen Menschen gestorben allerdings, das wollen wir hoffentlich nicht oder wir haben einen Impfstoff,
aber es wird nicht so sein, dass die Menschheit an dem Virus zugrundegeht, die Menschheit wird anders aussehen.
Aber wenn ich den Klimawandel dann weiterdenke, dann sieht das ganz verheerend aus.
Und ich glaube, das ist das Thema, das immer ansteht.
Jetzt sind wir, das ist so das, was wir machen auch im Labor, das sind Biopolymere, Biogas und so weiter,
aber warum bin ich jetzt vom Weltretten plötzlich an eine Hochschule für angewandte Wissenschaften gegangen?
Ganz ehrlich, also Lehre macht mir unglaublich Spaß, das ist einfach so.
Und das war für mich von Anfang an schon immer ein Aspekt, den ich faszinierend fand
und natürlich in der pharmazeutischen Industrie macht man keine Lehre, das ist klar.
Und das hat mir einfach gefehlt, also das war was, was ich schon immer auch machen wollte, was mir Spaß macht
und das ich dort auch machen kann.
Und wenn man eine Fachhochschulprofessur annimmt, sollte man auch mit diesem „Lehre macht Spaß“-Denken reingehen,
weil man hat da 18 SWS Lehrverpflichtung, das macht einem selber keinen Spaß, wenn man die ohne diesen…
Und was ich zu meinem Erstaunen festgestellt habe, man denkt immer, naja Lehre ist ja eigentlich alles Gerede.
Also man stellt sich dann da rein und erzählt den Kindern was und dann sind die alle glücklich
und diese pädagogischen Aspekte hat man vorher natürlich immer nur so peripher.
Dieser Punkt, was bei Lehre für mich neu war, ist, dass die Lehre selber ein Forschungsfeld sein kann.
Und da dachte ich eigentlich, da kann ich gar nichts dazu beitragen, weil eigentlich gibt es ja Menschen,
bei denen steht nicht auf dem Klingelschild Biotechnologie, sondern bei dem steht auf dem Klingelschild Pädagogik drauf.
Und natürlich die haben sich wahnsinnig Gedanken gemacht, wie man klassische Lehrformen verbessern kann und so weiter,
aber wenn es dann so Richtung e-Learning geht oder wenn es dann Richtung Labor geht,
da ist dann viel was dann auch noch zu beackern ist und das finde ich ganz spannend
und das ist auch was, wo jetzt teilweise so meine Forschung dann hingeht.
Bevor wir vielleicht auf diesen pädagogischen und Weiterentwicklungsaspekt der Lehre kommen,
vielleicht noch mal kurz so, was steht denn so im Fokus?
Also jetzt geht es hier sozusagen nach wie vor um Biotechnologie, aber jetzt haben wir sozusagen den nichthumanen Teil im Fokus unter anderem,
wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, geht es unter anderem auch um Alternativen zu Kunststoffen,
dass man also an der Stelle Sustainability erzeugt, ohne eben jetzt aus fossilen Quellen Kunststoffe herzustellen,
sondern stattdessen aus …?
Aus beispielsweise Abfallströmen aus der Lebensmittelindustrie Biopolymere herzustellen.
Derer gibt es ja eine Menge.
Ja.
Und ist das sozusagen noch so ein komplett umbestelltes Feld oder?
Nein, nein, da gibt es natürlich schon einige, die da auf dem Feld arbeiten, das ist jetzt nicht so, dass wir da die ersten sind,
die auf die Idee gekommen sind, bei Biogas ist es genau das gleiche.
Aber es gibt da noch eine Menge zu holen, also ich meine, wenn ich irgendwie in den Supermarkt gehe,
mich frustriert es maßlos, die Menge an Kunststoffen, die man dort heraustragen muss einfach.
Klar, es gibt natürlich interessante Alternativen, hier Unverpackt-Läden etc., nur das ist natürlich alles noch nicht so weit ausskaliert,
dass man davon sprechen könnte, dass es irgendwie besser wird, sondern es wird eigentlich derzeit nur noch schlechter.
Also schon vor zehn Jahren habe ich irgendwie deutlich weniger Kunststoff mit mir genommen aus dem Supermarkt als jetzt,
das ist zumindest so ein bisschen mein Gefühl, ich habe es nicht wirklich nachgemessen.
Was findet denn da gerade statt, also ist das sozusagen nur eine Grunderkenntnis, die man schon immer hatte
und jetzt nutzt man es das erste Mal oder reden wir gerade von technologischen Durchbrüchen,
die überhaupt erstmalig so eine Kunststoffentwicklung auf Basis solcher Materialien ermöglichen?
Das ist schon länger bekannt, das sind keine Durchbrüche, sondern das ist einfach, man erinnert sich dran
und fängt wieder auf dem Gebiet an.
Also man wusste lange, dass bestimmte Bakterien die produzieren das als Speicherstoff für ihren Stoffwechsel.
In schlechten Zeiten können die dann wieder den Speicher angreifen und das kann man als Biopolymer dann im Prinzip auch nehmen und rausextrahieren.
Das ist, wenn man das jetzt sieht, wie sieht es aber faktisch im Supermarkt aus, dann ist die Frage,
kann ich dann meine ganzen Tüten durch diese Biopolymere ersetzen?
Nie im Leben, also weil das ist einfach, die werden in hundert Jahren noch teurer sein als wenn ich das aus Erdöl oder so mache.
Also da muss man einfach auch mal realistisch sein.
Also ich war mit einem Kollegen, der ist Chemieingenieur, wir waren in Pittsburgh bei einem Chemieingenieurkongress
und haben dort ein Verfahren vorgestellt, das war Methan-Pyrolyse, das ist eine andere Baustelle
und da habe ich gesehen, in Amerika wird ja gefracked bis es kein Morgen gibt
und die Großchemie und Öl- und Gasindustrie, die hängen im Prinzip im gleichen Boot drin.
Und sobald, was für mich auch interessant war zu sehen, dann kam das Gas wieder hoch und war saubillig
und gleichzeitig wurden hunderte von neuen Kunststoffwerken dann gebaut.
Das heißt, die haben direkt neben die Gaswerke gleich eine Kunststofffabrik gemacht.
Und es ist einfach unglaublich billig, so einen Kunststoff herzustellen und auch verfahrenstechnisch ist es im Prinzip ein Traum,
Sie nehmen das Ethylen, das kommt da rein als Gas, dann polymerisieren Sie es und dann fällt Ihnen der Kunststoff unten raus, Punkt.
Vereinfacht gesagt, so sieht das chemische Verfahren aus.
Das ist natürlich konkurrenzlos gegen jegliches andere Verfahren, das muss man einfach realistisch sehen.
Wenn ich das in Bakterien mache, dann habe ich die in wässriger Lösung, dann müssen die das erst mal umsetzen,
das dauert viel länger, und dann muss ich diesen Kunststoff vor allem rausextrahieren aus diesen Bakterien.
Das heißt, das ist Lichtjahre von der Effizienz von so einem Polyethylenprozess weg.
Was das Bittere aber ist, das wird einfach gemacht, also das pressen die natürlich in den Markt,
das ist jetzt nicht so, dass jetzt hier zwei Tüten wieder da sind, sondern es geht dann natürlich,
ich war in Indonesien beispielsweise, da haben wir eine Partnerhochschule, man glaubt gar nicht,
auch da gibt es Kunststoffe ohne Ende, da gibt es aber keine Müllabfuhr und nichts, das landet natürlich alles direkt in den Flüssen.
Und hergestellt wird es hier, auch bei uns in Deutschland und dann wird es da einfach auf die Märkte gedrückt.
Und mit diesen Massenkunststoffen in diesem Maßstab kann ein Biopolymer nie konkurrieren.
Also das heißt, das ist immer zusammen mit dem Umdenken, dass man dann auch diese abbaubaren Kunststoffe hat.
Es sei denn, es gibt ein entsprechendes Steuersystem.
Zum Beispiel, aber auch diese Mengen wird man mit Biopolymeren nicht herstellen können.
Also es ist vollkommen illusorisch zu glauben, dass ich Biopolymere mache und die gleiche Kunststoffproduktion,
die wir jetzt hier haben, von den Eigenschaften will ich gar nicht reden, dass natürlich Biopolymere andere plastische Eigenschaften haben
wie die bekannten, die wir haben, aber auf die Mengen zu kommen, das schaffen Sie gar nicht.
Also da würde jeder Mais auf dem Acker würde in den Biopolymer reingehen.
Also das ist schon, da muss man auch realistisch sein.
Aber es ist wie bei den Impfstoffen auch, ich finde es wichtig, dass man sich anfängt, da mal mit dem Thema sich wieder zu beschäftigen
und einfach mal zu forschen und zu schauen, was kann man verbessern?
Und je mehr das machen desto besser ist das.
Also ich glaube, es ist auch so ein bisschen eine Verpflichtung für den Forscher, dass er sagt, das Thema, vielleicht kann ich da was beitragen, dann versuche ich das auch.
Aber das ist schon jetzt, sagen wir mal, das Kernthema im Rahmen dieser Studiengänge dort in Rhein-Waal?
Nein, nein, das ist jetzt das, was ich im Labor machen, das ist eben diese Biopolymere und das ist Biogas im weitesten Sinne.
Das ist jetzt nicht, dass wir im Studium nur über Biopolymere reden, das kommt vielleicht in der Vorlesung mal in angewandter Mikrobiologie mal am Rande vor, das war es.
Also das ist jetzt nicht 24/7.
Ich habe beispielsweise Wahlpflichtfachvorlesungen, medizinische Biotechnologie, da rede ich über pharmazeutische Biotechnologie,
das was ich vorher gemacht habe.
In einer Fachhochschule haben Sie ja einen relativen Strauß an Fächern, die Sie unterrichten.
Also ich unterrichte klassisch Bioverfahrenstechnik beispielsweise, angewandte Mikrobiologie,
da geht es natürlich um Infektionsbiologie, das was ich mitnehmen kann von früher.
Da ging es um Impfstoffe, da geht es aber auch um Biopolymere.
Und dann habe ich Immunologie als Wahlpflichtfach, das ist natürlich dann auch wieder was, was mein Kernbereich ist.
Aber industrielle Biotechnologie beispielsweise das bin ich jetzt am Abgeben, das macht man auch,
ich habe nie technische Enzyme produziert, das unterrichtet man auch, das ist ja der Punkt wieder,
Biotechnologie ist sehr sehr breit und natürlich ist der Studiengang bei uns auch sehr breit ausgelegt.
Es können nicht nur Biopolymere sein, das wäre nicht gut.
Jetzt haben Sie schon angedeutet, es geht auch so ein bisschen darum, die Hochschullehre selber weiter zu entwickeln.
Wenn man was weiterentwickelt, dann stellt man ja meistens erst mal fest, dass es auch irgendwo ineffizient ist
oder auf eine Art und Weise gediehen, wie es vielleicht nicht ganz so zukunftskompatibel ist,
was war denn da so Ihre Analyse?
Ach ineffizient bin ich immer sehr vorsichtig.
Also ich meine, es gibt gute Gründe, warum man bestimmte Sachen macht, wie man sie macht,
da muss man auch immer ein bisschen aufpassen, wenn man jetzt an das Schlagwort e-Learning denkt,
da war, als das aufkam, war die Idee, wir machen jetzt MOOCS, also wir stellen quasi die Vorlesung online,
Stanford und so weiter, die waren so die Vorreiter und plötzlich müssen die Leute gar nicht mehr in die Uni kommen und alle werden schlauer.
Da hat man aber plötzlich gesehen, unsere eigenen Studenten profitieren davon gar nicht,
weil man guckt sich das Ding halt mit so einer Tüte Chips nebendran an, hat aber gar keinen Bezug mehr zum Lehrenden auch
und die Faszination kommt dann natürlich da auch nicht rüber und dann macht das keinen Spaß und man macht das halt so nebenher
und das funktioniert einfach nicht.
Also das heißt, so das klassische Seminar, das jetzt typisch ist für Geisteswissenschaftler, das wird man nie ersetzen,
weil diese Lehrsituation ist sehr wertvoll und ist sehr wichtig.
Aber man kann es ergänzen, das ist der Punkt.
Also das heißt, es gibt bei uns in der Biotechnologie Mikrobiologie zum Beispiel, jeder muss den Zitratzyklus irgendwie können.
Das hat man in der Schule schon gemacht.
Und dann ist das jetzt natürlich so, das ist schon hundertmal irgendwie gelehrt worden,
kann man so was nicht auslagern und dann im Unterricht irgendwas vertiefen beispielsweise,
also diese Flipped Classroom Konzepte oder Blended Learning Konzepte.
Und das mehr und mehr reinbringen macht natürlich absolut Sinn.
Und das geht natürlich Hand in Hand mit einer Digitalisierung, weil das kann ich natürlich mit der digitalen Lehre viel einfacher machen.
Und dann auch qualitativ besser machen und ich denke, da ist noch viel zu tun und da kann man auch viel gewinnen.
Und da ist die Chance der Digitalisierung.
Jetzt hatten wir ja ein Corona-Semester, da muss man sagen, das ist ja super, das war ja ganz digital.
Nein, ganz im Gegenteil, für die Studierenden ist das natürlich verheerend, weil dieser Kontakt zum Lehrenden ist unglaublich wichtig.
Weil es macht einen Unterschied, ob ich ein Video angucke im Internet, ich gucke jetzt vorher ein YouTube-Video an mit süßen Katzenbabys
und dann mache ich dann mein Video, was weiß ich, Biopolymere, da ist das alles so eine gleiche Mischung
und der Bezug fehlt, es ist kein, selbst wenn man das noch so gut interaktiv macht, ich habe meine Vorlesung live gemacht,
beispielsweise werde das jetzt auch im Wintersemester machen, interaktiv als YouTube-Livestream
mit natürlich Interaktionen, Chat und so weiter, es fehlt trotzdem, also dieses Persönliche fehlt trotzdem.
Also das muss da sein, es ist verheerend, dass das bei Corona nicht ging, es ist wichtig, dass das später wieder kommt,
aber mit Corona hat man auch viele Sachen entwickelt, was man dann dazu mitnehmen kann.
Und das, glaube ich, bereichert dann die Lehre unglaublich.
Und ich rede jetzt eher so von der klassischen Lehre, also von Laboren rede ich noch gar nicht,
sondern die klassischen Vorlesungen, Seminare und so weiter.
Was ist denn der Zwischenstand, was hat sich denn sozusagen gezeigt, was eine sinnvolle Ergänzung sein kann,
die man vielleicht so bisher noch nicht gesehen hat oder die man noch zu zögerlich genutzt hat?
Was ist ein Zwischenfazit dieser Zeit?
Das ist ja nicht so, dass durch Corona die digitale Lehre erfunden wurde.
An manchen Stellen schon, habe ich den Eindruck, also in der Schule auf jeden Fall.
Also ich bin ja DigiFellow vom Stifterverband und bin jetzt auch HFD ab und zu mal unterwegs,
also das gab es vorher schon auch, also diese Konzepte sind da.
HFD ist?
Hochschulforum Digitalisierung und das ist, diese Leute, die sich damit beschäftigen, gab es schon länger,
die Konzepte sind jetzt auch nicht alle neu zu erfinden gewesen für das Corona-Semester.
Nur natürlich ist es, es gab einzelne, die haben das schon immer gemacht, aber es ist gar keine Frage für viele Kolleginnen und Kollegen,
die sagen sich, ja warum soll ich das tun, das ist der eine Punkt.
Der andere Punkte ist natürlich auch, wenn ich 18 SWS Lehre mache, ist es jetzt nicht so,
dass ich mal hoppla hopp geschwind alles auf Blended Digital mal kurz so umstellen kann, das ist nicht so einfach, das braucht auch Zeit.
Und tatsächlich ist diese Zeit jetzt auch teilweise da gewesen, das umzustellen.
Also meine Frau, die sitzt gerade nicht drin, die würde jetzt laut aufheulen, weil ich eigentlich im Sommersemester
praktisch jedes Wochenende Samstag und Sonntag acht Stunden im Büro gesessen bin.
Also da sagt die natürlich, wo war die Zeit?
Also wenn man diese Begeisterung hat, nimmt man sich die Zeit halt auch, weil man ja auch weiß, für was die da ist.
Also das heißt, das ist nicht neu erfunden worden, sondern es ist tatsächlich, ich glaube, im größeren Maßstab implementiert worden.
So würde ich das nennen.
Und man hat auch im größeren Maßstab dann eine Rückmeldung gekriegt, was funktioniert und was funktioniert nicht,
ich glaube, das ist so die große Chance, also dass man in der Breite jetzt mal digitale Lehre ausprobieren konnte oder musste,
aber man muss daraus die Chance erkennen, dass man sagt, das funktioniert, das funktioniert nicht.
Also das ist auch so ein Punkt, wie in der Wissenschaft auch, Dreivierteljahr funktioniert nichts,
also man muss dann auch draus lernen und ich glaube, das ist das Neue, dass man jetzt auch mal eine viel größere Rückmeldung hat,
die deutlich weniger theoretisch ist, sondern wesentlich praktischer.
Und was funktioniert, was funktioniert nicht, ich gebe mal ein Beispiel.
Ich sage mal, generell habe ich alle Vorlesungen als Livestream gemacht, die gleichzeitig aufgezeichnet,
dass ich dieses Material später dann in sinnvolle Blended Learning Pakete verpacken kann,
weil ich kann das nicht nochmal alles machen, das ist so eine Dual Use Geschichte.
Und ich habe gedacht, die Vorlesungen waren dann eigentlich, also klassische Vorlesungen sind die bei mir jetzt nie unbedingt,
aber so ist trotzdem eine Vorlesung gewesen, was ja auch typischerweise, was weiß ich, Zitratzyklus oder so,
das ist dann eine Vorlesung mit Interaktion und allem möglichen und ich dachte, naja im Prinzip sind Vorlesungen ja anderthalb Stunden,
also zwei Stunden in der Uni sind anderthalb Stunden Vorlesung, die am Stück waren, sind also diese Livestreams auch anderthalb Stunden gewesen,
aber die Rückmeldung, die ich dann, ich habe dann alle meine Kurse habe ich eine Evaluierung dann reingesetzt anonym für die Studierenden,
dass die mir eine Rückmeldung geben, man kriegt natürlich auch so Rückmeldungen, so ist es nicht,
aber man will das halt auch von allen, die sich sonst immer nicht melden
und was für mich überraschend war, obwohl das live war, obwohl das mit einer Interaktion war,
obwohl das eigentlich auch nichts anderes wie im Hörsaal war, kommt das an der andren Seite ganz anders an.
Also für die Studenten ist das deutlich anstrengender, sich dann diese anderthalb Stunden zu konzentrieren,
weil die eben doch daheim sitzen und die Tüte Chips liegt nebendran oder man läuft dann doch noch mal zum Kühlschrank oder was,
wie wenn es im Hörsaal ist, das habe ich zum Beispiel nicht erwartet.
Also ich werde jetzt wieder umstellen und diese Vorlesungen kürzer machen, also auch die Livevorlesung kürzer machen
und dann hoch interaktive, solche Zoom-Sessions dann hinten ranpacken als Beispiel.
Das habe ich vorher nicht gedacht.
Ich habe gedacht, das müsste doch eigentlich, das ist doch genau das gleiche, also nur als Beispiel.
Und das ist jetzt ja kein besonderes e-Learning, weil das ist ja im Prinzip nur die Vorlesung ins Digitale projiziert,
also da muss man jetzt nicht stolz drauf sei, dass man jetzt das e-Learning erfunden hat.
Aber was die Studierenden haben, für die die waren richtig begeistert, dass ich das gemacht habe, technisch ist das nicht ganz so trivial,
so ein YouTube-Livestream zu machen, das machen natürlich die ganzen Gamer, aber man muss schon, wenn man da ins kalte Wasser geworfen sind,
auch so ein bisschen reinwachsen, man muss so ein bisschen das auch wollen.
Also das will man jetzt auch keinem sagen, das musst du jetzt machen, sondern das muss man auch so wollen und dann geht das schon.
Aber ich hatte eine Veranstaltung, die war ein bisschen anders konzipiert, aber da gab es auch die Live-Vorlesung, das war eine Komponente
und diese Vorlesungen waren gar nicht mehr klausurrelevant, weil ich habe diesen Kurs so umgestellt,
dass die Prüfungsleistung gar keine Klausur mehr ist.
Das heißt, eigentlich braucht man die Vorlesung gar nicht angucken, um eine Eins zu kriegen, weil die Eins kriegt man sowieso mit was anderem.
Trotzdem waren von 70 Studierenden 45 live bei den Vorlesungen dabei, obwohl die eigentlich gar nicht …
also normalerweise wirft man den Studierenden ja immer vor, sie machen nur das, was sie absolut müssen.
Und ich habe eine Rückmeldung gekriegt, diese Studierenden haben das in der Corona-Zeit genossen,
dass da jetzt jemand live für sie einfach sich die Zeit nimmt und sie ernst nimmt und für sie live eben das macht,
nicht nur irgendwelche Folien aufnimmt, weil im Prinzip könnte man das ja auch, sondern live sitzt der da,
der Mensch sitzt in dem Augenblick an der anderen Seite und das war für die wahnsinnig wichtig.
Das ist auch so ein Erkenntnisgewinn, da habe ich gedacht, hey das hätte ich jetzt gar nicht gedacht.
Natürlich freut einen das, aber das ist was, was man gar nicht so auf dem Schirm hatte.
Also insofern gab es nicht neue Methoden, die man jetzt erfunden hat, sondern man hat viel lernen können aus,
wie das dann tatsächlich auf der anderen Seite ankommt.
Na, das ist ein sozialer Faktor, der, glaube ich, jenseits noch des eigentlichen Inhalts steht und einen Wert für sich darstellt.
Jetzt gibt es, glaube ich, auch noch Versuche, so speziell mit digitalen Werkzeugen noch zu arbeiten, mit so Smart Glasses, was steckt da dahinter?
Genau, das ist ein anderer Bereich, das eine sind jetzt diese klassischen Vorlesungen, Seminare und so weiter,
das andere, was wir natürlich gerade in naturwissenschaftlichen Studiengängen haben, wie Biotechnologie nunmal ist,
ist relativ viel Labor, also dass man Chemie oder Mikrobiologielabor und so weiter hat.
Und da gab es ja Digitalisierung bisher gar nicht, also da gab es auch keine…
vom Methodischen her sieht ein Labor aus wie vor hundert Jahren, natürlich sind die Geräte jetzt ein bisschen schicker
oder Mikrobiologie sieht inhaltlich ganz anders aus als vor hundert Jahren, aber das Mikrobiologielabor sieht gleich aus.
Also die Art wie da gearbeitet wird sieht gleich aus.
Und die Laborarbeit ist auch wichtig, weil Sie müssen so wie Gitarre, mein Sohn spielt jetzt traumhaft Gitarre,
ich habe es ein Dreivierteljahr versucht und bin dann am F gescheitert, aber Gitarre lernen heißt,
es nützt nichts, wenn ich mir ein YouTube-Video anschaue, wo mir jemand erklärt, wie man das spielen kann, die Finger müssen das können.
Und genau das gleiche ist beim Labor auch, das sind die einen Sachen, man muss das einfach vom Händischen einfach bearbeiten können.
Das heißt, da ist eine Übung dabei und man muss diese händische Geschicklichkeit erlernen.
Und das kann man nur im Labor, ich kann nicht eine virtuelle Realität machen, wo ich dann plötzlich das alles kann,
das geht nicht, ich kann auch nicht mit VR Gitarre lernen, das geht genau so wenig und das gehört dazu.
Also bei den naturwissenschaftlichen Studiengängen ist es tatsächlich so, das Händchen und das Köpfchen gehen zusammen, das geht auseinander nicht.
Das heißt, ich kann ein Labor nicht einfach so ersetzen und deshalb hat man auch immer gesagt zurecht,
es macht keinen Sinn, das Labor ins Digitale auszulagern.
Aber das heißt natürlich nicht, dass ich nicht digitale Instrumente benutzen kann, um die Qualität in diesen Laboren zu verbessern.
Und das war die Idee mit diesen Smart Classes eben, man hat bestimmte Probleme von der Qualität her.
Ein typisches naturwissenschaftliches Labor sieht so aus, Praktikum sieht so, ich habe 30 Studenten und zwei Betreuer.
Und natürlich können Sie nicht allen 30 gleichzeitig auf die Finger gucken.
Jetzt gibt es Versuche, die sehen erstmal nicht kompliziert aus, aber in Wahrheit, wenn ich jetzt über eine CFU-Bestimmung mache,
eine Lebendkeimzahlbestimmung, im Prinzip ist das Pipettieren, Verdünnungsreihe pipettieren, dann auf eine Platte pipettieren,
ausplattieren, das war es und dann kann ich zurückrechnen, wie viele Bakterien sind da vorher in meinem Reagenzglas drin gewesen?
Jetzt kann man sagen, naja was soll das Problem sein, sagen die Studierenden natürlich auch.
Also ich habe das einmal gemacht, alles ist gut.
Was wir die machen lassen ist, wir lassen die alle genau die gleiche Probe analysieren
und die Ergebnisse unterscheiden sich dann regelmäßig nicht um ein paar Prozent, sondern um den Faktor 10 hoch 5.
Und dann sagen die Studenten genauso, mhh.
Das heißt, da sind die Fehlerquellen, die sieht man so gar nicht in der Methode und die muss man spüren.
Und jetzt ist aber das Problem, wenn ich den Studenten frage, ich sehe das an das Ergebnis und sage,
das sieht so aus, wie wenn du die Pipettenspitze nicht gewechselt hättest, wenn du von einem Gefäß ins andere gehst.
Und dann sagen die natürlich, nein, ganz ganz sicher.
Und dann ist es natürlich der Lerneffekt, weil ich den natürlich nicht beaufsichtigen kann und meistens so die Selbstreflexion manchmal auch fehlt,
ist dann vermindert, weil wenn die das selber auf bestimmte Fehler, die die vielleicht auch im Eifer des Gefechts gar nicht sehen können,
weil die gar keine Zeit haben, weil das natürlich auch Stress ist, wenn man so was macht,
hat man dieses Lernen aus den eigenen Fehlern einfach nur vermindert.
Und mit den Glasses hat man die Möglichkeit, dass man solche Schritte beispielsweise aufzeichnen lässt.
Man sagt, okay der macht jetzt diese Verdünnungsreihe und dann sage ich, es könnte sein, dass man diese …
Wir reden jetzt quasi von so einem Brillengestell mit einer eingebauten Kamera?
Genau, nicht nur, das hat eine eingebaute Kamera drin.
Aber auch.
Auch, das heißt, ich kann nachher nochmal kontrollieren, was habe ich da gemacht, das ist ein Punkt.
Das kann natürlich gleichzeitig auch der Dozent, ich kann dann sagen, okay ich schaue mir mal an, wie ist das gelaufen,
kann dann beispielsweise zeigen, da ist das und das falsch gelaufen, weil ich nicht alle gleichzeitig anschauen kann.
Mit den Smart Glasses kann ich aber noch mehr.
Das eine Problem ist, dass man den Fehler da nicht sieht, das andere Problem ist, dass ein Student da reinkommt
und einfach überfordert ist und natürlich sollten die sich vorbereiten, tun die im Regelfall auch,
aber manche Versuche sind einfach auch komplexer, das heißt, wir haben natürlich Videos gemacht, wie man den Versuch macht,
erklärt und so weiter, trotzdem kommt man am nächsten Tag an und hat die Hälfte vergessen,
und so einen Versuch muss man auch in einem gewissen Flow durchziehen, sonst funktioniert das nicht.
Wenn man ständig dann auf das Skript gucken muss und nachgucken muss und so weiter, dann failt der.
Und die Idee ist da, dass man dieses Information dann über diese Smart Glasses dann einspiegelt,
dass man nicht ständig alles wieder weglegen muss und wieder reingucken muss.
Quasi so ein Teleprompter für den Prozessablauf.
Im Prinzip ein Teleprompter für den Prozessablauf, dass man sicherstellen kann, dass der Prozess richtig geht.
Dass man tatsächlich das mit den Händen lernen kann und dass es nicht dran scheitert, dass der Prozess schon nicht stimmt.
Und das ist die Idee mit den Smart Glasses, also die zwei Sachen, dass man zum einen komplexere Prozesse qualitativ besser hinkriegen kann
und zum zweiten, dass man eine Rückmeldung hat, hat das eigentlich geklappt oder nicht?
Und man kann das natürlich weitertreiben, dann kann ich natürlich sagen, das sind diese Grundlaborpraktika,
aber die Gerätschaften, die wir einsetzen, werden natürlich immer komplexer.
Wenn ich einen Bioreaktor habe, die sind natürlich hochkomplex und so ein Studierender, den würde ich da eigentlich gar nicht erst mal ransetzen,
weil der braucht natürlich erst mal zwei Stunden Einweisung.
Ich kann als Professor aber jetzt nicht jeden Studenten bei 80 Studenten im Semester erstmal da lange einweisen.
Und so viele Assistenten hat man auch nicht.
Hätte ich gerne, ich würde das auch gerne machen.
Aber da kann man natürlich auch für solche Geräte dann eine Einweisung machen, wo ich auch remote dann beispielsweise wieder eingreifen kann.
Also sprich, diese Brillen in unseren Augen bringen wahnsinnig Chancen gerade im Laborbereich für Praktika, hands on Praktika.
Also nicht Corona-Remote, dass die Studenten gar nicht im Labor sind, sondern die sind im Labor, aber können da davon profitieren.
Das ist so ein Projekt, was wir auch forschungsmäßig dann machen und wo wir versuchen weiterzuentwickeln.
Heißt das, dass dann diese Smart Glasses auch selber mitentwickelt werden oder arbeitet man da mit anderen Universitäten zusammen,
die dann diese Entwicklung machen oder sind das fertige Produkte, die man so kaufen kann?
Also wir sind natürlich keine, sagen wir mal, Leute, die Smart Glasses bauen können, sondern da muss man auf Lösungen zurückgreifen, die es schon gibt.
Wir sind natürlich schon mal eingeschränkt von der Auswahl, weil wir können nur Smart Glasses nehmen, die im Zusammenspiel mit Laborbrillen funktionieren.
Also die meisten, diese netten Google Glasses, die es mal, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es die noch gibt.
Nein.
Aber die es mal gab, die könnte ich im Labor gar nicht nehmen, weil die brauchen Schutzbrillen die Leute.
Also das heißt, die meisten, dies es auf dem Markt gibt, fallen schon mal weg.
Und wir sind tatsächlich mit den Firmen dann schon in Interaktion, dass wir rückspiegeln, was für uns für das Labor wichtig ist.
Also die aktuellen, die wir nehmen, von der Firma, die sind schon wirklich ein Quantensprung für uns.
Die sind sprachgesteuert, die kommen aus einem Industriesetting, das heißt, die Smart Glasses waren in anderen Settings schon regulär eingesetzt,
das ist also nicht so, dass für unsere Anwendung die neu erfunden werden müssten, sondern wenn Sie jetzt im Logistikbereich oder irgendwas werden die eingesetzt
oder auch, wenn Sie im Industriebereich einen Mechaniker hinschicken, der irgendwelche Maschinen wartet,
da ist mit dem Smart Glas dann möglicherweise sein Kollege verbunden und die können dem dann geschwind die Anleitung reinschießen oder irgendwas.
Die Brillen sind dann aber in einem Umfeld, wo es laut ist und so weiter und der muss trotzdem die natürlich bedienen können
und genau diese Brillen sind für uns optimal, weil auch im Labor ist ja da ständig irgendwie Gerede oder Lüftungen laufen oder so was,
also die müssen dann so von den Ausrichtungen so sein, dass ich die bedienen kann, auch wenn da noch ein gewisses Stimmwirrwarr zum Beispiel da ist.
Das heißt, die gibt es und dann spiegeln wir den Firmen schon zurück, was für unsere Zwecke optimal wäre.
Die hören sich das jetzt natürlich erst mal an, weil die Frage ist dann nachher, wenn der Markt dann da ist, wird das weiterentwickelt,
aber die sind da schon offen, also hören da schon zu, also das ist schon ganz gut.
Jetzt ist natürlich dieses Projekt dieses Jahr lief da gar nichts, weil es war kein Student an der Uni und ohne die geht es nicht.
Naja, dann vielleicht von zu Hause live überragen.
Ja, das ist natürlich, man ist immer auf der Suche nach Geld, das ist so.
Ich habe mit diesem Projekt auch schon mehrere Anträge gestellt, einer ist beim Stifterverband, aber einen EU-Antrag,
ein großer für zwei Jahre Konsortium mit sieben Partnern aus fünf Ländern, das ist die oberste Förderlinie, was den Bildungsbereich betrifft in der Europäischen Union,
das ist so wie so das Horizon2020 auf Bildung und da sind 20 Millionen Euro drin in dem Programm.
Ist noch was zu holen.
Naja, also insgesamt 20 Millionen, nicht für ein Projekt, sondern insgesamt, europaweit 20 Millionen für Bildung.
Da geht noch was.
Also das ist schon sehr traurig.
Eine Million kann man dann rausholen in dem Projekt.
Wir sind gescheitert, aber das jetzt nicht, da mache ich der EU auch gar keinen Vorwurf, das sind halt so Projekt, das immer so zwischendrin liegt,
aber ich denke, gerade da im Bildungsbereich ist schon noch Luft nach oben auch was die Finanzierung betrifft,
weil es gibt kaum Fördermittel da und wenn es die gibt, sind die gnadenlos unterfinanziert, also das ist leider so.
Zum Abschluss wollte ich noch auf eine andere Aktivität hinweisen, die Sie aufgenommen haben, ich glaube, das ist im letzten Jahr entstanden, die Lectures for Future.
Man hört es schon, hier ist eine gewisse Nähe zum Scientists for Future, was ja selber wiederum sich an die Klimaproteste angeschlossen hat, die Fridays for Future.
Also was war das für eine Idee und was ist da passiert?
Ja, wir haben ja nach Corona schon mal kurz das Thema Klima angesprochen und tatsächlich kann keinen das Thema Klima im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes kalt lassen,
und ich glaube, als Wissenschaftler hat man da auch, der Steuerzahler zahlt uns und man hat dann auch eine bestimmte Verpflichtung,
die man draus ableiten muss, also dass man da nicht einfach die Augen verschließen kann und sagen, wird schon, wird nicht.
Und die Fridays for Future das war, ich glaube, für viele von uns Wissenschaftlern, die auch schon ein bisschen frustriert waren,
weil man hat publiziert ohne Ende, ich habe jetzt nicht im Klimabereich publiziert, aber die Klimawissenschaftler sagen ja schon seit Jahren,
warnen vor dem Klimawandel mit Daten, wenn die Daten bei mir in der Biologie jemals so solide gewesen wären, das wäre ein Traum gewesen.
Also es git da gar nichts groß zu rütteln, es hat aber keinen interessiert.
Und dann kam das Paris 2015, was wirklich einen riesigen Jubel ausgelöst hat, dass sich die Nationen drauf geeinigt haben,
auf Klimaziele 2050 muss CO2 auf Null sein, das haben die in Paris alle unterschrieben, das hat man kaum für möglich gehalten
und das hat funktioniert, da war der Jubel groß und dann war das unterschrieben und dann ist eigentlich nichts passiert.
Und das war, man ist dann da gestanden mit großen Augen und hat gesagt, das kann doch nicht wahr sein.
Angela Merkel hat das unterschrieben, die ist Physikerin, die weiß genau, was sie da unterschrieben hat und alle anderen auch und es passiert nichts.
Und dann kam diese Fridays for Future Bewegung und das war als Wissenschaftler so ein Hallo-Wach-Effekt,
hoi, die nehmen ja plötzlich das Zeug ernst, was die Wissenschaftler produziert haben, lesen das und sagen das den Politikern,
hey Leute lest das mal, ihr müsst was tun.
Und dann finde ich als Wissenschaftler ist es ein bisschen komisch, wenn man den Kindern das überlässt, also nach dem Motto, das auf die Kinder abschiebt,
es ist jetzt euer Job dafür zu sorgen, dass das auch ernst genommen wird, was wir da schreiben.
Das ist doch eure Zukunft, könnt ihr selber retten.
Genau, das ist eure Zukunft, und das ist ein bisschen komisch.
Das heißt also, man muss, weil es gibt in der Wissenschaft bezüglich Klimawandel, natürlich gibt es in der Wissenschaft so lebwissenschaftlich immer ein paar Positionen,
die in die eine Richtung gehen, aber ich würde mal sagen, wie war das, ich glaube da gab es eine Studie, 99,27 Prozent der Publikationen sind,
klar Klimawandel gibt es, ist stark und so weiter, und da gibt es im Prinzip wissenschaftlich übersetzt heißt das, es gibt gar keinen Zweifel aus der Wissenschaft raus.
Und dann ist es eigentlich eine Verpflichtung zu sagen, hey es muss was passieren, wir können nicht nur die Kinder auf die Straße schicken,
meine Kinder waren auch auf der Straße und der Papa sitzt dann da am Frühstückstisch und sagt, geht ihr mal demonstrieren, ich bohre in der Nase.
Das ist so der Punkt, das geht einfach nicht.
Und da kam dann drauf die Idee, was kann man denn machen, und da kam diese Idee mit diesen Lectures for Future auf.
Die Scientists for Future die haben - Lectures for Future und Scientists for Future das ist nichts anderes, das ist im Prinzip das gleiche -
das ist im Prinzip, Lectures for Future würde ich so als eine Aktion nennen, aber das ist natürlich eingebettet.
Ich bin jetzt auch im wissenschaftlichen Beirat bei den Scientists for Future drin, also das sind keine unterschiedlichen Bereiche, das sind ja alles Wissenschaftler.
Ja, aber das ist mal ein klares Label, an dem man ja sozusagen auch schnell relevanten Content dann einstellen und dann entsprechend auch finden kann,
darum geht es ja, glaube ich, primär.
Ja, genau. Also die Idee war da eigentlich ursprünglich, dass man sagt, Professoren dürfen ja nicht streiken, das ist auch gut so,
es wäre noch schöner, wenn Beamte dann auch anfangen zu streiken, aber wir haben eine Freiheit der Lehre
und die Idee war, dass man die Freiheit der Lehre auch mal wirklich ausnutzt.
Und das heißt, man sagt, ich nehme beispielsweise in Bioverfahrenstechnik eine Einheit in Bioverfahrenstechnik war nur Klima
und eben nicht Bioverfahrenstechnik, das heißt, die Studenten sind dann tatsächlich 1/15 dümmer was Bioverfahrenstechnik betrifft
und haben da dafür was in Klima gelernt.
Ob das die jetzt in zehn Jahren wirklich so wesentlich dümmer gemacht hat, wage ich zu bezweifeln,
weil ich weiß, da ich meine Studierenden öfter sehe, wenn ich meine Grundvorlesung in Mikrobiologie zwei Jahre später wieder frage,
was sie da davon noch wissen, ist, glaube ich, das nicht so problematisch, wie sich das manche vorstellen,
aber das ist, so ein Zeichen zu setzen, dass Klima einfach wichtig ist, nach innen und nach außen,
dass wir Professoren das auch machen und das war auch eine wesentliche Idee da dahinter.
Ich hatte auch so den Eindruck, dass die Scientists for Future Bewegung auch, es war also, sagen wir mal so,
als eine applaudierenswürdige Bewegung, sie war in gewisser Hinsicht auch überfällig, aber sie war ja im Prinzip auch eine Lehre,
nämlich eine Lehre aus dieser Zeit von, warum hört uns denn eigentlich keiner zu?
weil ich denke schon, dass die Wissenschaft in gewisser Hinsicht auch immer angenommen hat,
dass das sozusagen, ich will nicht sagen ausreicht, aber das ist halt dieser normale Prozess, so macht man das,
ja wir publizieren doch und jetzt ist es doch publiziert, was wollt ihr denn, wir haben es doch allen gesagt.
Nur dass diese Kommunikation nicht auszureichen scheint, das ist, glaube ich, auch eine Erkenntnis,
die erst langsam eingesetzt hat.
Genau, also das glaube ich auch.
Es gibt natürlich auch, es ist auch nicht so, dass bei den Scientists for Future, dass jeder Wissenschaftler da dabei ist
und man kann natürlich auch durchaus argumentieren und so sagen, ein Wissenschaftler hat sich da gefälligst zurückzuhalten.
Also die Position gibt es natürlich, meine Position ist das nicht.
Weil ich sage, beim Klimawandel können wir uns diese Position einfach nicht erlauben.
Bei vielen anderen Sachen ist das gut, dass man sich zurückhält und es kann auch nicht sein,
wie wir vorher schon gesagt haben, dass in einer Gesellschaft dann plötzlich die Wissenschaftler regieren oder so,
das ist dann keine Demokratie mehr, aber wenn man merkt, das ist wieder ähnlich wie bei den Impfstoffen,
es ist ja nicht so, dass in der Diskussion jetzt da ist, dass die Leute sagen, den Klimawandel gibt es,
und die Konsequenzen, die uns aufgezeigt werden, die verheerend sind, wenn wir es einfach so weiterlaufen lassen,
wir als Gesellschaft wägen das jetzt einfach ab und akzeptieren das, sondern es wird ja so diskutiert nach dem Motto,
ach wird schon nicht so schlimm und dann muss man sich hinstellen und sagen, nein, nein, das wird genauso schlimm.
Und wenn ich das will als Gesellschaft, dass ich einfach ins Verderben laufe, ist das wieder eine gesellschaftliche Entscheidung.
Allerdings muss ich da als Wissenschaftler schon hin stehen und sagen, ey, das müsst ihr aber euch schon sehr genau überlegen,
weil es wird so schlimm, es ist ein in die Tasche lügen zu sagen, es wird schon irgendwie gutgehen, das wird es nicht.
Und das ist das, was Fridays for Future sagt und das ist natürlich wahnsinnig unangenehm,
weil die Fridays for Future quengeln da so rum, wenn man Kinder hat, kennt man das ja,
und man tut das normalerweise immer so ab, das Blöde ist, die haben recht.
2015 haben das alle Nationen unterschrieben und die sagen uns einfach, es wird so schlimm.
Und wenn ihr schon Paris unterschrieben habt und es eigentlich akzeptiert habt, dass man was dagegen tun muss, dann muss man auch damit anfangen.
Und das ist ja eigentlich das um was es geht.
Und ich glaube, da steht die Wissenschaft dann im Prinzip dahinter und sagt, die Fakten sind da,
also auch was es zu tun und so weiter, das ist entwickelt, also es geht nicht mehr drum, noch eine Publikation draus zu machen.
Natürlich machen die Klimaforscher weiter, so ist es nicht, also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich sage,
die sollen jetzt ihre Forschung einstellen, aber das wird nichts helfen, sondern es geht darum zu sagen,
es muss was passieren, wenn wir Paris unterschreiben und eigentlich alle uns einig sind, dass was passieren muss, dann müssen wir es auch tun.
Ja, man wünscht sich ja auch ein bisschen mehr wütende Wissenschaftler.
So allein schon, weil das ja genau der Nimbus ist, den sie normalerweise nicht an den Tag legen und sich auch ein bisschen unwohl dabei fühlen,
aber dieses kantigere Auftreten, denke ich, bewirkt auch schon etwas.
Also es ist, ich sage ja nicht, es muss jetzt komplett übertrieben werden, aber immer nur zu sagen, was richtig ist,
das ist so das eine, aber auch mal wirklich darauf hinzuweisen, dass hier politische Versäumnisse im Raum stehen,
ist, glaube ich, auch ein wichtiger neuer Aspekt.
Ja, aber auch da, ich bin immer vorsichtig, ich wünsche mir wütende Wissenschaftler, will ich so ein bisschen abmildern,
weil ich glaube, wichtig ist, und das ist vielleicht auch so ein bisschen die Tendenz, dass wir Wissenschaftler den Auftrag haben,
die Diskussion wieder zurückzubringen auf ein richtiges Maß.
Wir haben vorher gesagt, in der Talkshow ist es jetzt so, da sitzt ein Wissenschaftler und nebendran sitzt einer, der hat zwei YouTube-Videos geguckt
und im Prinzip ist die Meinung, die er hat, gleichwertig wie diese Faktenmeinung des Wissenschaftlers.
Der Wissenschaftler ist nicht besser oder schlechter als ein Mensch, aber der ist in seinem Fachgebiet sicher fundierter, ja.
Und wenn es um Fachfragen geht, Kernspaltung funktioniert so und so, dann weiß das der Wissenschaftler.
Wenn es um Fragen geht, Klimawandel und so weiter, dann ist es wichtig, dass man diese Fakten akzeptiert.
Weil beim Klimawandel ist es so glockenklar wie sonst nirgends.
Natürlich gibt es Bereiche in der Wissenschaft, die viel kontroverser sind, da ist es schwierig auch,
das in die Bevölkerung zu spiegeln, weil, sagen wir mal, ein Normalsterblicher wird kaum verstehen,
warum jetzt lang der Streit war, warum ist eine T-Helferzelle, die TH17-Zelle, soll das eine eigene Zellpopulation sein, ja oder nein?
Was natürlich für Impfung auch so eine Relevanz macht, das kann man von keinem verlangen.
Aber beim Klimawandel ist es was anderes, das ist direkt da, direkte Konsequenz, da ist es wichtig.
Aber wichtig ist, dass die Gesellschaft wieder zurückkommt auf dieses Respektieren von Fakten und dass es klar ist,
Fakten und Meinung ist was anderes.
Es darf jeder eine Meinung haben, aber man darf keine Fakten und Meinungen gleichsetzen.
Also ich glaube, das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt und deshalb müssen die Wissenschaftler wütend sein insofern,
nicht weil sie sagen, ihr habt den Klimawandel nicht verstanden, sondern ey wir müssen erst mal wieder auf eine Diskussionsbasis kommen.
Weil eigentlich ist es ja auch unverschämt, da sitzt jetzt einer, der hat zwei YouTube-Videos gesehen,
kommt zu mir und sagt, ich weiß es eigentlich besser und da muss man sich eigentlich auch fragen,
sag mal, was ist eigentlich jetzt komisch?
Eigentlich ist man als Wissenschaftler sein Leben lang in der Ausbildung in dem Bereich seit 30 Jahren
und einer mit zwei YouTube-Videos hat das jetzt alles rausgeholt.
Scheint aber auch noch ein anderes Problem zu geben, nicht nur so diese vollständigen Wissenschaftsagnostiker,
sondern teilweise natürlich auch, ich sage mal, Leute mit wissenschaftlichen Hintergrund, die sich sehr daran gewöhnt haben, die Medien zu bespielen
und von daher auch immer ansprechbar sind und dann bisweilen, ich will da keine Namen nennen, aber so ein bisschen den Eindruck machen,
als wäre es dann sozusagen ihr Beruf ausschließlich ihre Meinung dann kundzutun, was sie ja dann sozusagen auch als Wissenschaftler tun.
Während auf der anderen Seite oft viele Wissenschaftler immer sagen, naja ach die Öffentlichkeit und so, das ist ja gar nicht so mein Ding,
ich muckle hier lieber so ein bisschen in meinem Labor rum, ich habe eine Meinung, ich unterschreibe auch mal so einen Aufruf
und einen öffentlichen Brief, aber ansonsten muss ich jetzt hier nicht unbedingt in die sendende Seite wechseln.
Ich glaube, das ist aber auch nicht so durchzuhalten oder?
Es ist auch nicht so einfach, weil ich glaube, da gibt es auch keine einfachen Antworten.
Also das muss man auch erst lernen, also ich glaube, was Sie sagen ist natürlich ein Problem.
Wenn jetzt plötzlich alle Wissenschaftler rausspringen und irgendwas erzählen, auch zu Fachgebieten, wo die eigentlich gar nichts zu sagen haben, ist es schwierig.
Ich komme ja auch nicht aus der Klimaforschung, ganz ehrlich, also trotzdem sage ich was.
Was ich aber kann ist wissenschaftlich denken, das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt.
Das heißt, was ich sage ist, die Studienlage, die da ist, die diese Kolleginnen und Kollegen kreiert haben, die aus diesem Bereich kommen,
kann ich als Wissenschaftler nachvollziehen, warum diese Studienergebnisse grundsolide sind.
Weil das vom wissenschaftlichen Standpunkt sauber gemacht wurde.
Das kann ich als Wissenschaftler, egal ob ich in dem Bereich drin bin oder nicht, beurteilen.
Und deshalb kann ich das unterstützen.
Aber wenn ich jetzt in jede Talkshow reingehe und plötzlich als der Experte für Klimafolgenforschung da reinsetze,
da muss man dann irgendwann auch sagen, jetzt mal vorsichtig, also da gibt es Leute, die können das und man sollte nicht zu weit aus seinem Fenster springen.
Also dieses sprechen Sie auch so ein bisschen an.
Aber man muss natürlich immer so ein bisschen über seinen Schatten springen und ich glaube, dieses Umdenken bei Wissenschaftlern,
dass man das auch tut, ist wichtig und das ist für uns aus diesen Lectures for Future was ganz tolles, was wir da mitgenommen haben,
weil das war ja bewusst eben keine Aktion, die sich nur an Klimawissenschaftler richtet.
Bei denen ist es ja klar, eine Vorlesung in Klimawissenschaften, ich glaube nicht, dass Sie da irgendeinen Studierenden überzeugen müssen
oder nach außen irgendwas tun müssen, sondern da waren Theologen dabei, da waren Musiker dabei, da war alles dabei.
Und das war wahnsinnig spannend, weil die Leute auch dann teilweise den Bezug zu ihrem eigenen Gebiet gesehen haben.
Und das ist wichtig, das heißt, dieses Integrieren von so einem Thema in eine wesentlich breitere wissenschaftliche Basis fand ich wichtig.
Und das hat natürlich einen soziologischen Aspekt, wenn Sie jetzt den Klimawandel weitertreiben,
wenn Afrika unbewohnbar ist, Sie werden Flüchtlingsströme haben, das ist dann wieder was, was die Soziologen sich anschauen.
Das heißt, diese ganzen Punkte, die greifen übereinander und das ist so, dass man dann auch ein bisschen immer über seinen Bereich springen muss
und das konnten die Wissenschaftler, glaube ich, vor 20 Jahren noch gar nicht.
Ja, das scheint auf jeden Fall eine neue Disziplin zu sein, die jetzt sozusagen mit in den wissenschaftlichen Kanon mit aufgenommen wird.
Gut so, kann ich nur sagen.
Wir sind jetzt, glaube ich, am Ende, wenn wir nicht noch irgendwas ganz wichtiges vergessen haben vielleicht noch anzusprechen, gibt es noch was?
Ach wir haben sicherlich viele wichtige Sachen vergessen, aber ich glaube, irgendwann ist auch ein Ende.
Genau, damit alles noch eine Zukunft hat.
Herr Fensterle, vielen vielen Dank für die Ausführungen über Bioengineering und Lectures for Future und was wir sonst noch alles besprochen haben.
Ja, ich bedanke mich, es war ein Vergnügen, ich weiß gar nicht, was wir alles besprochen haben,
aber das Gute ist, Sie haben es ja aufgenommen.
Genau, alles eigentlich, alles was wichtig war, heute zumindest.
Ja und ich bedanke mich wie über für’s Zuhören hier bei Forschergeist.
Und ich sage, tschüss und bis bald.